next book notes with author james lowen
[Music]
this week on book notes our guest is
james lowen professor of sociology at
the university of vermont
he joins us to discuss his recent book
lies my teacher told me
everything your american history
textbook got wrong
[Music]
james lowen author of lies my teacher
told me can you remember a lie that your
teacher told you and when oh yes
some of the lies i have to admit are
lies of omissions
i remember learning when i was 42 years
old that the united states had put
troops into the soviet union
in order to support the white side of
the white red
civil war that was going on in 1918
and i learned that those troops stayed
there two years in conjunction with
japanese troops and some british and
french naval support they went all the
way to lake baikal in the middle of
siberia
we also had troops up in murmansk and
archangel up near norway
and i thought how is it that i a history
minor in college
never learned that so i went back to my
college history book written by
richard hofstetter at all
and
i found everything that hofstadter had
deigned to tell me about that
invasion we could really call it and it
was the following half sentence
speaking about world war one american
troops were withdrawn from europe by
1918 with the exception of a contingent
from vladivostok in 1920.
so there's a half sentence about how we
took our troops out of vladivostok on
april fool's day it turned out in 1920.
nothing at all about how we put them in
that's an example
what was the origin of this book
i taught for many years at tougaloo
college a college in mississippi that is
predominantly african-american
then i moved to the university of
vermont so i went from the blackest to
the whitest college in america when i
was at tougaloo i was
distraught by the fact that my students
believed
the following myth about reconstruction
they believed that reconstruction was
that time period when
blacks took over the government of the
southern states right after the civil
war but they were too soon out of
slavery and so they messed up and whites
had to take control again
now that's a terrible misstatement of
what happened in reconstruction for one
thing the southern states were governed
by a black white coalition led by whites
they did not go under black control for
another thing many of the southern
states particularly mississippi had good
government during reconstruction in
mississippi the state government during
that time period started the public
schools for both races whites as well as
blacks wrote a terrific new constitution
and did other things
and i thought what must it do to people
to believe erroneously that the one time
that they were on the center stage of
history in american in the american past
they messed up what does that do to your
self-concept so i looked into
how had my students learned this why did
they believe it
and
tougaloo was a good college is a good
college they had learned what was in
their high school state history books so
i put together a coalition of students
and faculty
and we wrote a new history of
mississippi called mississippi conflict
and change the state rejected it for
public school use and uh it's another
story but we actually took them to court
about that and won a first amendment
victory
so then i moved to vermont and i
realized that in this way as in so many
other ways mississippi was not exactly
different from the united states as a
whole it was just an exaggeration in
other words i got interested in american
history not just state history and
realized that it too suffers from
tremendous distortions and omissions and
even lies what's your reaction when you
drive down the highway and you see
historical marker ahead
and they stop and then you stop and you
read it how often do you believe it
i don't i haven't done a percentage
maybe half the time
it's a very important question because i
call it lies on the landscape i mean
we've got these historical markers all
over the united states the first problem
with them is what isn't commemorated i
mean all kinds of major events go
unremarked because the controversial or
because they don't maybe show the united
states in the best light
a recent one i i drove past in fact i
was situated near it for a week
is in upstate new york
and i
was teaching on one of the finger lakes
teaching a bunch of history teachers
actually
and uh there's a marker there for
general sullivan's raid against the
iroquois
during the american revolution
and it's got some very interesting
double speak in which
the malading
indians
messed up the settlers and therefore the
army came in and punished the indians
and moved the frontier a couple of
hundred miles west
well if you think about who's the
settlers the settlers are actually the
iroquois and in fact part of what
sullivan did was burn their cornfields
destroy their orchards and tear down
their houses they were settlers these
were not wandering people these were not
nomads um
the the um marker could best be
understood using a phrase from from
william buckley polemics history as the
polemics written by the victors
you say in the back that you worked on
this book for 11 years yes
where
uh at the university of vermont i spent
two years also at the smithsonian
institution i'm possibly the only living
american who has slogged through
12 high school history textbooks from
cover to cover and and then besides that
um i had to do a lot of research
on
the things i've just talked about for
instance the the
putting of troops into the soviet union
so that i would make sure that i got the
facts straight
back in the back flat this is going to
be a little bit difficult to do we'll
get a close-up of it are the 12
textbooks yes that you you wrote about
how did you choose these 12
well for various reasons i wanted to
pick some of the best sellers so that i
would cover at least
the textbooks that more than half of our
students read and
there's one book in particular
used to be called rise of the american
nation and after we lost the war in
vietnam it got re-titled triumph of the
american nation it has over a fourth of
the market by itself
um
publishers are
leery of
divulging sales figures so it's a little
hard to know after that one what's the
best seller but i tried to include
several of the very popular books i also
included two older books these are
called inquiry textbooks and they were
written during the 1970s and they were a
little different the other 10 books we
would call narrative textbooks they just
telestrate chronology and they tell it
pretty much in the authorial voice the
kind of omnipresent omniscient godlike
here's what happened and then here's
what happened next
but the inquiry textbooks include
more emphasis on primary sources and
then they ask students questions that
hopefully get them thinking
these textbooks are no longer in print
the inquiry text movement uh didn't find
favor with teachers and it went out of
existence do people who write high
school texts
for history make a lot of money
they do if they vote triumph of the
american nation that is if you get
one-fourth of the market that is a
bonanza and
uh
every textbook it seems and every
publisher wants to have that book and
therefore these books end up clones of
each other
uh
it surprises me
if you think about it the city in which
we are speaking washington dc the school
board is under black control the same is
true for detroit for new york city for
many other cities and for some districts
in mississippi for instance but there is
no black-oriented uh
u.s history there's no u.s history that
in fact is what we might call um
multi-centric i would say they are all
eurocentric they are all clones of each
other because each one wants to be the
next triumph of the american nation
how does a book start
if i if you or i we're going to write a
history book i think the first thing
that
scott forsman or macmillan or whoever
was engaging us would do
is they would send us five or six
competitors and they would say this is
what you're up against
and
i believe they would be saying also
make sure your book includes the stuff
these books include
and the result of that is that
the process is supposed to be one in
which the textbook is based on the
underlying secondary literature in
history there's a terrific secondary
literature in history it's what i read
it's what i based uh lies my teacher on
uh my teacher told me on it is not uh a
matter of you have to go back to the
primary sources in every uh little
detail but the textbooks are not based
on the huge secondary literature in
history they're based on each other and
thus they repeat some errors that go all
the way back to the 1890s
but who
is there anybody out there that kind of
puts their imprimatur on textbooks that
say okay this one's all right that one
isn't and and if they're if they do that
who who are they that's a good question
in one sense no there isn't that is you
would think the history profession might
or there might be a review journal
basically history textbooks are not
reviewed at least high school textbooks
even college texts which are generally
not reviewed by anybody by anybody the
history profession
considers them a little bit dirty that
is like if i were
a historian and i were applying for a
new job at
the university of washington and i'm
already at the university of vermont
the fact that i might have written a
history textbook would not count in my
favor if i'm looking for tenure if i'm
looking for advancement they are looking
the dean's and the history
departments they are looking for me to
write a wonderful monograph on andrew
jackson or whatever my wonderful
monograph is about they're not looking
for a textbook they consider them kind
of dirty kind of done for profit
at the university of vermont the former
dean made a distinction between
scholarship and what he called pedagogy
and textbooks would fit under that
latter
thing heading and get very little credit
and the same holds even for the review
journals they're busy they take their
time writing reviews of
monographs they do not bother reviewing
textbooks particularly high school
textbooks
it was the first time you ever got
interested in history
i got interested in history as a result
of being interested in sociology in fact
i have to say that to me good history is
the sociology of the past uh this will
probably
exercise
some historians listening but it seems
to me that uh the important thing we
want to know about the past is how did
it shape us what are the main things
going on that caused us to be what we
are like today
and going to mississippi uh which i did
actually as an undergraduate for a
semester and then going back there as a
as a faculty member where were you in
school when you were i was at carleton
college as a undergraduate
in minnesota and i took my junior
semester abroad as it were this was way
back in 1963
and it was right after the ole miss riot
and i went to mississippi state which
was then the largest all-white
segregated institution of higher
learning outside of south africa it did
not have a single black student in fact
the only black student in any white
school in the state was one person james
meredith at ole miss so that was a great
time to go
it was a great time to see social change
happening right before my eyes and
naturally i got interested in the past
how did you get to carlton college in
the first place
and how many how many african-americans
were there at carlton college
when i went to carlton college i started
in 1960 i applied from illinois it's not
an unusual thing to do from the midwest
i had good sat scores and fairly good
grades and
actually i had some family involvement
at the college so i had known about it
i went to school with a person who was
the sixth black student in the history
of the college and the college was 100
years old
now since then
carlton has done a much better job i
understand the school is now eight or
nine percent black which is quite good
for a college located in rural minnesota
that meant however that when i was a
junior i had almost no experience with
black people particularly in college
actually i did to some extent in high
school which is another reason i wanted
to go to mississippi i wanted to learn
about a society that was different from
the midwest in which i grew up what was
the town in the midwest you grew up in
decatur illinois
what did your parents do there
my father was a doctor my mother was a
housewife and then also a junior high
school librarian what kind of family was
it how many brothers and sisters uh one
sister
we lived in the white part of town we
were republicans and just pretty
straightforward but there was a strain
of idealism in the family and maybe both
my father and mother and i think that
got imparted to me i hope it has
because i think that there's a lot of
idealism in american history some of
which i bring out in uh in the book lies
my teacher told me you dedicate this
book
to all american history teachers
who teach against their textbooks
how come that's true i think that's
actually what needs to be done
uh
if we think about textbooks now this is
a very interesting point just think
about the titles of textbooks in
chemistry
a high school history chemistry textbook
is likely to be called chemistry
or principles of chemistry or
introduction to chemistry the same is
true in mathematics the same is true
even in english literature but in
history very few books are called
american history
or something bland like that they're
called rise of the american nation
triumph of the american nation the great
experiment the great republic land of
the free these are real titles
what is that saying i think that's
saying that we are not just entering
another subject we are not just going to
learn about history we are going to
salute it we're going to salute the flag
it's going to be an exercise in
nationalism
i think that's wrong because i think we
develop stronger citizens and certainly
more knowledgeable people more
knowledgeable about how we got where we
are
if we teach history with all of its dirt
and its glory with all of its questions
with his good guys and its bad guys
instead of only good guys
so
how can a history teacher deal with that
people often ask me what book do you
recommend i don't recommend a book
i don't know a history textbook that
treats history the way a chemistry
textbook treats chemistry as something
to be studied worth learning about
period so i think that a good
teacher has to use a history textbook
but then maybe maybe from reading lies
or from reading other works of secondary
history teach against that textbook get
students thinking about it get students
thinking about why is the textbook
leaving out this stuff why is it saying
this one it's
false or this one it's not when it's
misleading
this book is done by new press yes who
are they
the new press is a bunch of folks who
were as i understand it thrown out of
pantheon when
a man a millionaire named newhouse took
over random house
and so for about the last three or four
years they have been a very interesting
press
they get foundation grants i think they
call themselves a
non-profit commercial press and they're
the only such thing um the couple of the
famous books are the book race by studs
circle and they also published the
supreme court tapes that were caused a
great controversy a year or two ago when
the supreme court wasn't sure that they
wanted their tapes probably peter iron's
book yes may it please the court i
noticed that the cartoon on the cover is
done by jeff danziger who is also a
vermonter do you know him
not personally he actually illustrated a
short story i wrote once and uh so i
know him professionally
where is the university of vermont it's
in burlington
and how did you
decide to go there
well at the time when i decided to leave
tougaloo
there were several
universities that were interested in me
uh the university of vermont
particularly appealed because it was
setting up a phd program in applied
sociology which is one of the things i
do this means sociology
often used in court and i'm an expert
witness in civil rights cases
particularly but in other kinds of cases
too
so they wanted me for that reason and i
wanted to go to a pioneering phd program
in applied sociology after i got there
the next year there was a retrenchment
and the phd program never went through
i enjoy the landscape it's a beautiful
town
and i'm there you say that what is it
four out of five
high school students that go to college
do not take history courses
i think the statistic is something like
83 percent of
folks who graduate from high school
never take another history course that
includes the folks who don't go to
college at all as well as those who go
to college and don't take history you
start the whole book out by saying that
high school students hate history yes
there's poll after poll that shows that
history is the least liked subject
history and social studies and things
like it
to my surprise because i always had
trouble with foreign language
foreign languages much better like than
history mathematics often is the most
liked subject english science history
always comes in last
i think there's some reasons for that
one is
the incredible boring nature of the
textbook
these textbooks average i think 888
pages
probably every viewer will remember the
incredible list of questions at the end
of each chapter that you're supposed to
memorize answers to
um
there's no way that you can learn i
counted them for one textbook and came
up with over 2000 questions
there's no way that you can
remember at the end of a semester at the
end of the year these 2000 plus factoids
and what you're not learning is the
basic important questions and issues so
you don't have any skeleton to put all
these little details uh onto
it's not a very light subject uh anybody
who's black or female or
asian american or whatever
is going to feel alienated from it but
in my experience affluent whites are
just as alienated at least just as bored
you uh
talk about and here's a picture we'll
show of someone by the name of helen
keller yes
who was she helen keller is of course
known to most of us as the famous
blind and deaf girl who could that is
who overcame
and i've asked hundreds of people mostly
my students also other audiences to tell
me what she did with her life after she
overcame
uh exactly two people out of over a
thousand have known and one of those
learned it indirectly from me and the
other one is
married to a deaf person and in the deaf
community they do know what she did
but it's very ironic that although we
get all these educational films about
helen keller there's something like a
dozen of them on the market and although
almost every student gets some
indoctrination as to this wonderful
woman who did something no one knows
what she did once she learned how to how
to read and write and uh
speak what did she do well she became a
radical socialist she first became a
member of the massachusetts socialist
party and when that wasn't far enough
left for she became a wobbly a member of
the international
workers of the world the iww
and the reason she did this is actually
related to her blindness
because she wanted to do something to
help blind people and she came to
realize that blindness is not um
distributed amongst the social system
just randomly it's particularly back
then maybe even today it's concentrated
in the lower class
that's because of industrial accidents
that blinded people it's because of
syphilis carried by prostitutes who are
mostly poor and it's primarily of course
cut due to bad medical care
so she realized that if she was just to
spend the rest of her life working on
the braille alphabet which she had done
some work on improving
or doing other things like that she was
merely treating the symptom not the
cause so she became a socialist well i'm
not here to push socialism uh but it's
very interesting that when she became a
socialist she was probably the most
famous woman on the planet because of
all the attention that had been given
her when she learned how to speak when
she graduated from radcliffe college and
so on and suddenly from the most famous
she became the most notorious and all
these newspapers that had lauded her now
proceeded to distance themselves from
her and say well of course she's the
captive of people around her she doesn't
really think independently and so on
and she took them to task she wrote
letters to them saying uh i blush to
think how how you uh how highly you
spoke of me
a couple of years ago how stupid i must
have become in the in the interim uh and
she wrote a letter to the brooklyn eagle
which was a very major newspaper it was
the newspaper that walt whitman had
written for in the in the 19th century
that had been one of these newspapers
that now attacked her and she said it is
the brooklyn eagle that is socially
blind and deaf uh she says i may ha i
may not have been able to see this the
sweatshops and the to see the factories
um or to hear them but i have smelled
them and in fact she did go on tours all
across america
so she became really uh quite a
humanitarian on behalf of
um decreasing social stratification
you know yeah in what year she died
i think it was 1969 or so she lived a
long life and
until quite recently
if i understand it right she is buried
at national cathedral yes along with
annie sullivan her teacher i don't know
about annie probably the reason i
mention it is she's also buried in the
same place where woodrow wilson is
buried and you combine the two as you
start off here what's
what do the two why did you mention the
two up front well my first chapter is
about heroes and what textbooks do to
heroes and the two heroes i pick on are
in fact uh helen keller and woodrow
wilson and both of them did some heroic
things and deserve to be treated as
heroes both of them also uh are talked
about with amazing omissions the
omission about helen keller we've
already discussed
wilson of course
issued his 14 points
attempted to
argue for democracy at versailles
also passed various things through the
congress during his progressive era
as president but wilson had at least two
um
shall we say
two feet of clay maybe uh two two
blemishes
one was his incredible racism uh he was
surely the most racist president since
before the civil war ended slavery he
was of course a white southerner and
when he came to power
which was with the aid of considerable
white votes excuse me black votes who
were trying the democratic party and
trying its claims for progressivism
he proceeded to segregate washington dc
he segregated the federal cafeterias
federal workplaces if two people one
white and one black had been sorting
mail together they now had to be in
separate rooms or have a screen between
them
he also stopped blacks from various
political appointments that had been
routinely given them since the days of
lincoln and grant
and it's no coincidence that late in his
term the signals he was giving off about
race relations
penetrated the nation and we had a wave
of race riots from about 1917 through at
least 1920 um i mentioned in lies my
teacher told me
possibly the first example of bombing
civilians by aircraft certainly the
first example in united states history
came about in tulsa oklahoma when
there was a race riot against the black
community in tulsa and it even included
dr flying a
biplane probably uh airplane above the
black community and dropping dynamite
into it killing more than 70 people so
these are race riots that actually
far out do
the riots that we hear so much about in
terms of the rodney king riot in los
angeles or the watts riot
did you find any of this
in any of the 12 textbooks you looked at
oh there's a little mention of it
some of the textbooks let's say maybe
five of them
we'll mention
that
woodrow wilson
uh did some segregation usually without
an active verb
for instance one textbook actually says
that uh the federal government uh
segregated or work rooms in the federal
government were segregated and then
woodrow wilson undid that
and and called a halt to it the second
statement is just totally false he never
did that uh he never called a halt to it
but there's a common practice of
whenever anything bad is mentioned it's
put in the passive voice as if nobody
did it it just happened
um the other problem with woodrow wilson
of course was his invasion of the soviet
union and of so many countries in latin
america he put troops into mexico a
total of 13 different times and also
nicaragua haiti dominican republic
and some of the things that
american soldiers ended up doing and
some of the people they ended up
supporting have come back to haunt us
from the dictatorship in haiti which
is
we helped install to that the trujillo
dictatorship in the dominican republic
and so on
now
i'm not trying to just bad mouth udo
wilson but i am suggesting that we need
to put him in perspective that um
we need to be aware of the bad as well
as the good but somehow the textbooks
have trouble with any wart with any
blemish on somebody who's supposed to be
a hero was this a tough book for your
publisher with legal problems did they
have a lot of lawyers have to go over
this
not that i know of i mean the things
that you say about these 12 textbooks
aren't of concern to the lawyers at new
press
i don't think so for one thing um
unlike textbooks this book is footnoted
so whenever there's a um
whenever i'm assuming that this is how
things really were as opposed to this is
what the textbooks say they were i do
provide documentation for that
otherwise i was generally quoting
textbook authors and quoting what they
said and i think people can be quoted
from held responsible would you use any
of the 12 books that you reviewed in any
history course yes
i would have them available as basically
as backup uh i personally wouldn't teach
a high school history or even a college
history text or textbook in a course
because they cover so many things
this is there's no need to have 888
pages of all kinds of little details i
would rather focus on 10 or 12 major
issues chronologically arranged that
bring forth what
the important
points are that still have relevance to
the present
but
for teachers who do want to use a
textbook maybe they feel that they will
get too much parental criticism if they
don't or maybe they feel that there's
all these little facts that their
students are going to be asked on the
s.a.t or on the new york regents exam or
something like that
fine i have no quarrel with using a
textbook so long as the teacher
and helps the students learn against the
textbook put the textbook in perspective
critique the textbook for its omissions
you have a picture and your book of a
t-shirt that you can buy you say over at
the library of
congress that has six different faces of
columbus on it yes what's the point the
point is incidentally it's my son nick
is modeling that t-shirt uh the point of
those six pictures that the library of
congress makes is we don't know what
columbus looked like um there's no known
picture for sure that was painted of him
while he was alive
uh the six pictures are very different
one from another
this gets then into the question why
do each textbook why does each textbook
include a picture
of columbus
a head and shoulders picture
and
i think it's for the purpose of
iconography not inquiry um
unless you believe we can read character
from iset
i think these head and shoulders
pictures are pretty boring in the first
place but in the case of columbus we
don't even know what his eyes look like
so we certainly aren't reading anything
from it that's legitimate
so why include it
um
because it's heroic because it's an
exercise in hero worship that's the
point i'm making by including and i
think that's kind of why they why they
sell the textbook i think the t-shirt
thanksgiving day
a wonderful day
what about it where does it stand in
history well
that's that's
very interesting a lot of people think
of course that thanksgiving goes back to
1620 to the pilgrims that we've had
thanksgiving day ever since uh
i gave a whole talk for an hour at the
smithsonian about thanksgiving a year
and a half ago the first point to know
about thanksgiving is that it was
actually invented by abraham lincoln in
the middle of the civil war and the
first thanksgiving that is in our modern
series happened in 1863 and it was
basically giving thanks for the slow
victory of the troops particularly that
previous summer in
vicksburg and at gettysburg and the fact
that the union was going to be held
together and that slavery was going to
be ended
but it's maybe more interesting to go
back to um
ask the question what were the pilgrims
really thankful for
and this gets into the
issue of the famous plague
but i shouldn't say the famous plague
because almost nobody's ever heard of it
this is the plague of 1617 or 1618
happened just two three years before the
pilgrims set foot in massachusetts
and it was a plague of enormous
proportions in fact i i used the perhaps
unfortunate one-liner that it made the
black death in europe pale by comparison
the black death killed one out of every
three europeans
over a period of three years
this plague in massachusetts killed
between 90 and 96 of all the people
living there
who were these people these of course
were indian people
and so the pilgrims were very aware of
this in fact king james the the king who
of course uh
commissioned the king james version of
the bible he called it that wondrous
plague among the salvages because back
then they
spelled savages with an l
and
various pilgrim and puritan leaders
considered that this plague and some
later plagues were sent by god to wipe
out the indians title to this place and
confer it onto the to the pilgrims and
it's one of the reasons therefore most
likely that the pilgrims ended up in
massachusetts rather than in virginia
where they were thinking of going or in
guiana which they were actually
contemplating
they get to massachusetts
and
what the students all know about it is
that they had a tough winter and then an
indian named squanto comes along and
squando can speak english miraculously
and he helps them plant fish heads among
the corn and it grows tall and the rest
is all thanksgiving
and
what what's ironic about that story is
that squando himself provides a
wonderful
hook a wonderful point of entry to the
whole
plague story the plague is one of the
most important geopolitical events
happening anywhere on the earth in the
first quarter of the 1600s because it
means that nobody's going to oppose
the british settlement of massachusetts
in fact the indians are going to welcome
it
and squanto played the following role
he missed the plague why because he had
been enslaved probably twice
uh quite possibly taken once to england
spent several years there in the service
of of a rich man
who then finally sent him back to
massachusetts then he gets enslaved
again in about 1617 taken to malaga
spain
enslaved there he escapes from slavery
in malaga he escapes from spain makes
his way to britain talks his way back to
massachusetts on a fishing boat actually
took him two trips because the first
boat only went to newfoundland and he
thought maybe he could get a ride from
newfoundland to massachusetts couldn't
do it went back to britain this man has
been across the atlantic six times he's
more traveled than any pilgrim
and yet what the textbooks say one
textbook for instance i quote says um he
had learned english he explained from
passing british fishermen
period that's all they say
i guess that's true although they not
only passed they sold him into slavery
in england and into spain
well he missed the plague
he gets set back onto
american soil he walks to his home
village only to make the unbelievable
discovery that every person there is a
corpse
and it's at this point that the pilgrims
come on the scene he's a man without a
tribe his
community has ended that's why he throws
in his life his lot with the pilgrims
now that's a story that's a story where
some drama is a lot better than this
pious thing about uh planting the corn
and the uh pulling the fish heads in the
corn and it grew tall and he was then
very important to the
pilgrims for the first two or three
years until he did
finally die of a different disease
the pilgrims all knew this for instance
there's one who writes in a diary
in this bay where we now live formally
dwelled two thousand indians because
they moved directly into the village
with all the corpses they moved into the
village that
people had lived in renamed it plymouth
the rest is history as we say but it
isn't history because it keeps getting
left out of our history textbooks you do
an analysis of the number of pages
devoted
to the different decades
and you say the closer you get
to the present the less pages devoted in
these history books that's true how come
i think it's again because the recent
past is controversial
you and i for instance might talk about
the vietnam war we both remember it uh
we might i hope at least i do we might
talk about the uh women's movement uh we
might talk about the civil rights
movement
and and we're the age of parents uh
parents have opinions about these things
they lived through it
and they don't all hold the same opinion
and and therefore
there's some controversy going on now
it would be difficult i suspect for any
group of parents to have an argument
about the war of 1812.
there are actually some controversial
details and issues about the war of
1812. we could talk about them later but
they're not hot topics they're not going
to get history books rejected um i quote
a holt reinhardt and winston
representative who says the following
ooh by the way who's hole reinhard a
major textbook publisher i think they're
now part of harcourt brace and that's
probably part of something else and it's
probably all ultimately owned by uh
newhouse i don't know anyway um
this representative said if there's some
something controversial in a history
book
better to take it out
well
the recent past has the potential for
being controversial
um
the vietnam war is an interesting case
in point if you actually
look at public opinion polls on the
vietnam war you see that at this point
and for the last 10 years at least
70 of the american people believe
that the vietnam war was neither
politically correct nor morally correct
that is it was a mistake for us to do it
and it was also morally wrong that's at
least 70 well that's a whopping 70 30 uh
majority so that's not very
controversial but nonetheless the
textbooks leave out everything about the
vietnam war that has any guts to it that
has any controversy to it um the photos
that they show for instance um there are
maybe half a dozen famous photographs of
the vietnam war
i've asked people who lived through that
era to tell me what are these photos and
there's remarkable consensus the photo
of the naked girl having just been
napalmed i actually get emotional with
this photo uh running along highway one
uh the photo of the uh monk burning
himself i i have only to [ __ ] my hand
and people say oh yes that photo they
remember it these are famous photos
they're still used in the news today
even some of my students have seen it
the milai massacre photo the famous
photo of the evacuation from saigon
these are the five that i concluded are
the most
important photographs of the war because
they moved american public opinion and
they also show some of the issues of the
war such as the fact that the issue was
a um
[Music]
that there were no front lines and that
we were
firing upon the civilian population and
you include this photo how come because
that's a typical photo that the
textbooks do include this is a photo of
lyndon johnson surrounded by happy
troops at comrade bay a naval
uh
base that we built in vietnam
and it's a very different mood and
a very less important image an image
that didn't move american public opinion
and it didn't really describe very much
about the war in vietnam
so i counted in all 12 books how many of
the textbooks included any of these five
famous photos
the result one book included one
11 books included none of them they just
included photos like the lbj photo did
you
try to reach any of these 12 book
authors and ask them yes what did the
name talk to you oh yes
about the about the vietnam issues very
interesting that you that you raised
that question um
two authors uh davidson and lydle
wrote two different american history
books i believe
certainly they wrote one that is in my
sample
they also wrote a very fine book called
after the fact and after the fact is
aimed maybe primarily at high school
no not college history majors
and the title itself is upon indicating
that history is written after the fact
afterwards but also that historians go
after the fact and in after the fact
they have a chapter on each of various
issues in american history that they
think deserve a lot of attention
they have a chapter or most of a chapter
on the milai massacre and they argue
that the milai massacre is very very
important uh they they say it's
important because first of all it
influenced american public opinion when
these
famous photos of the children and the
old ladies and the old men lying in the
ditch having been shot by american
forces point blank when those photos hit
life or look magazine i think it was
life
when the story of the massacre occurred
that moved american public opinion and
in fact uh davidson and lytle argue that
it influenced hollywood that we hardly
ever see a movie about vietnam that
hasn't been influenced by me lime
imagery so they're important the second
reason that they say they're important
is because they claim i think correctly
so that the me lie massacre was not an
isolated incident that it was maybe an
exaggerated
incident but nonetheless an exaggerated
case of policies that happened a lot
that practices that happened a lot that
there were continued attacks on the
civilian population of vietnam and i
even quote william westmoreland about
that he of course was the general in
charge of the uh entire war from our
side saying uh well it does deny
the enemy population doesn't it um
so
it was an
issue in vietnam and an issue in terms
of policy so it's very important
they say what do they do in their
textbook they don't mention me lie
doesn't occur in the index it's not in
the textbook and they don't mention the
type of
anti-civilian act that milai symbolized
now that's
uh that's bad history
and in fact when i was talking with them
i complimented their their wonderful
book after the fact and i asked them
what about their textbook and um mr
lytle was speaking with me and he said
well i call my textbook a mcdonald's
version of history and i asked him what
does that mean and he said well
it means it's bland if it had any flavor
it wouldn't sell
why
he believes and his publishers believe
obviously that if it had any
flavor anything interesting in it then
it would upset some people and that the
way to sell the textbook is to make it
as bland as possible as uncontroversial
as possible
do you know
in fact that then all the teachers that
use these textbooks do not teach a lot
more of vietnam i notice that you have a
statistic in here that says the average
teacher spends between zero and 4.5
minutes a year
teaching vietnam how do you know that
well that was from i footnote that
that's research done by someone else who
did study it at least in the state of
massachusetts where he was from i
suspect that it's true
i've talked with a lot of students
hundreds actually because i asked my
introductory sociology students
about their experience with american
history and i've asked many of them
whether they ever got to vietnam and i
know when i took history of course the
vietnam war had not happened but we
didn't even get to
the second world war or we got just to
the end of it
and i did take history after the korean
war and after lots of other things
happen what happens is
these books are daunting and teachers
just don't reach the end of it in fact
one famous example there's the
the book
i think there's a book called teacher
anyway it's a big bestseller of a couple
of years ago
in which the author followed a teacher
in holyoke massachusetts as she went
through the school year
and by the end of the year she had just
gotten to reconstruction she was still
back in 1866 or so
well such a teacher obviously is not
going to teach about the one vietnam
you say that the
disney world
has a presentation of 29 minute
presentation
history of the united states in which it
leaves out completely leaves out vietnam
the ghetto riots of the 60s and the 90s
did you ask anybody why that's the case
no i didn't talk with anybody yet why
did you point it out what was the reason
well i would think it's a reasonable
description of disney history
i remember also another example of
disney history
i i went to the new york world's fair of
1964 whenever it was something like that
and they had an animated version of like
a three-dimensional sculpture of abraham
lincoln that walked and talked and said
stuff and he spoke for three or four
minutes
without ever mentioning slavery
so we're in the amazing situation that
we don't remember the vietnam war we
don't remember slavery as an issue even
connected with abraham lincoln and this
is what i call feel-good history
somebody else might call it disneyland
or disney world history
i think that there's some there must be
some belief on the part of someone uh in
the publishing houses or in the textbook
adoption boards
that the way to promote strong citizens
is by lying to them by by giving them
this feel-good history that just
tells them that the united states is the
best country has ever been and we never
did anything wrong
i don't hold that belief i think the way
to develop strong citizens is to get
them involved in the
issues of history and see that there
have been americans who have argued for
positive wonderful just principles and
are remembered around the world and
there have been americans that have
argued for oppressive principles and are
remembered around the world for that and
sometimes even the same americans have
argued on both sides and that i think
would get students involved with the
issues of history rather than just
kind of vote patriotism
you quote
from the challenge of freedom which is
one of the history books
the following thing president kennedy
and his administration responded to the
call for racial equality in june 1963
the president asked for congressional
action on far-reaching equal rights laws
why did you quote that
the textbooks again
want to heroize everybody and the number
one hero becomes the federal government
well if as i mentioned earlier if they
can't have a blemish
then when they talk about the federal
government as the hero they can't have a
blemish in their treatment of the
federal government this is very unusual
because after watergate and after iran
conjugate and all of our other uh
scandals of the late 60s and 70s and
even into the 80s and 90s
i think the american people have grown
lightly
suspicious or at least thoughtful about
the federal government and don't just
think that it always does the right
thing our textbooks still present it as
uh the be-all and end-all and the
do-gooder of everything now i
participated in the civil rights
movement i've mentioned that i was in
mississippi
and there was a poster
that
the movement offices had up on their
walls during the
1964 mississippi freedom summer
and that poster said
there's a street in itabina called
freedom
there's a town in mississippi called
liberty
there's a department in washington
called justice
now that's a bitter poster because of
course uh there was very little freedom
in the little delta town of itabina
there was very little liberty in the
nasty mississippi town of liberty and
they were arguing therefore there's very
little justice coming out of washington
and during the kennedy administration
the main response of the federal
government was made in fact by the fbi
now what did the fbi actually do with
regard to the civil rights movement well
first of all uh we have to realize that
the fbi didn't have an office in
mississippi and didn't have very many
offices in the south at all when it did
those officers were all staffed by white
southerners the fbi at this time had not
a single black
officer
hoover claimed it did because he counted
his two chauffeurs
they were black but that was it
but beyond that
the fbi
claimed that it was not its job to
protect or even to investigate
threats of violence that came to civil
rights workers
and again beyond that uh j edgar hoover
made it his policy he thought that the
brown versus board of education decision
was wrong and outlandish and he made it
his policy to investigate
civil rights movement people so as we
know he tapped king's phone
he
tapped the
hotel rooms that civil rights movement
organizers
operated out of or met in
he
made a well not he but uh fbi agents
made a tape
of king's
phone calls and
conversations in his room
often having to do with sex
and sent it to
coretta scott king
hoping to persuade king
to commit suicide now this is a
documented fact again i'm not inventing
this fact i'm just citing the
professional literature in history
that's why there's not going to be
lawsuits against the new press because
of this
so that's the kind of role that uh the
federal government played with regard to
the civil rights that's part of its role
with regard to the civil rights movement
and kennedy himself
even even a very
uh
thoroughgoing kennedy supporter like
arthur schlesinger writes something like
um
in the area of civil rights did not
bring out the best of the kennedy
presidency or something like that um
my own college tougaloo college was
investigated by the fbi as a threat to
america because it was uh in favor of
civil rights
what's the result of of all this well a
lot of bitterness on the part of the
civil rights movement but to what what
did the textbook say they say that the
federal government did the civil rights
that is that it passed the uh 1964 civil
rights bill the 1965 voting rights bill
and so on that it just kind of did it
this has a terrible payoff for the
president i think
to my surprise i've had a lot of
conversations in the last year with
young african-americans and a lot of
black people these days think that
integration actually is wrong and they
look back with nostalgia to the days of
segregation and separate black schools
these are people who generally were not
born in that era and they don't realize
what a terrible era this was
but the textbooks play right into their
hands because the textbooks have
the entire integration movement as being
done by the federal government
when actually the integration movement
was done by mostly black private
citizens who risked their lives to get
the federal government to enforce the
civil rights laws dating back to
reconstruction
so there's kind of room there for for a
paranoia that the textbooks feed by
telling
the black community and for that matter
the white community that the federal
government has always done things for
black people
blacks become paranoid what are these
things are they a good idea and i think
it encourages whites to become racist
and say
well if the federal government has
always been doing these wonderful things
for black folks haven't we done enough
why do we need to do more what's the
problem how would you describe your own
politics
oh very mixed i have in the last five
years i have voted for
republicans democrats and we have also
in vermont a socialist or progressive
he's called
congressperson the only non-republican
non-democrat in the congress and at the
risk of of uh invading the sanctity of
the ballot booth i have to admit that i
voted for him on occasions bernie
sanders yes
um where do you live
in south burlington vermont how big is
the university
about ten thousand eleven thousand and
how many courses a semester do you teach
five oh five a year two some semesters
three the next what kind what are the
what are the names of i mostly teach
sociology um i'm not in the department
of history uh i like to teach race
relations and i teach it almost every
semester it's a it's a searing
experience i mean
some of my black students get angry with
me some of my white students get angry
with me for for various reasons and so
you have to
develop a thick skin to teach race
relations even in a place that might
seemingly be as removed from the issues
as vermont what's the
what's the percentage of students at the
university of vermont that are
african-american
well i had her in class last semester um
she was now to be serious we have done a
terrible job of recruiting
african-american students when i first
went there there were 75 black students
uh that's out of approximately 10 000.
now you might say well what's the matter
with that because vermont's so white and
vermont is the white estate but we
recruit over half of our students from
out of state and not only from out of
state but from metropolitan areas
including this one and including new
york and philadelphia but when we have
recruited in
uh washington we typically recruit from
bethesda or from the suburbs of
philadelphia
not so much when i got there when we had
75 we then had an admissions director
who cared and who was making efforts to
increase that percentage
but he left and uh the person who
followed him who's thankfully now gone
didn't care about this issue and we
actually fell down to something like 28
black students i think now we're back up
to 50.
in other words it's a minuscule
percentage
in the acknowledgments in the front of
the book you
say the people listed below in
alphabetical order talked with me
commented on chapters suggested sources
corrected my mistakes provided moral
support i just want to go over some of
them lucy lowen that's my daughter
how old is she she's now 22
she and my son nick lowan who's also
listed there
did read chapters and i also had them
doing some fact finding for me what's
your son do nick um he right now he
works in a delicatessen in san francisco
he's been accepted into the peace corps
and hopes to go to uh guinea in west
africa you list
francis fitzgerald
who is francis fitzgerald she wrote
possibly the the most direct predecessor
to my book uh a rather famous book
called america revised that came out i
think in 1979 and that was a
hard-hitting study of history textbooks
also that first got serialized in the
new yorker and then was a bestseller
her book is different from mine in that
she mostly looks at the form of
textbooks and how the form has changed
over time and she decries the fact that
for instance instead of telling a story
they now interrupt it with all kinds of
uh blobs of pictures and little boxes
with special things she doesn't get as
far into the
facts of oh for instance the plague and
the pilgrims and so on and and decry
what they are saying it's not so much a
content book as it is a form book
richard currant james mcpherson
roger kennedy and his john franklin john
hope franklin
no john franklin is john hope franklin's
son who works at the smithsonian
but the first three you named are major
historians and
they either
responded to my pleas for help on
specific points or they read chapters
and commented on them or both
anybody upset with you
i hope so
i certainly hope that publishers will be
upset with me
not personally but i hope that they will
realize that it just doesn't do to
attempt to write non-controversial
boring history um
there may be a couple of other groups
that are upset with me
for instance
mel gabler is a
textbook critic in textbook in texas
and for the last 20 or 30 years he and
his wife and an organization that he
started
have greatly influenced textbook
adoption because texas is an adoption
state now i mentioned that about half
the states are adoption states texas is
the biggest one
publishers don't want to lose that
market
vermont has no influence over textbooks
um states that don't adopt statewide
have no influence over textbooks because
they have 500 or
200 or whatever school boards and school
districts that are adopting
district-wide or sometimes even
different principles are or different
high schools are adopting just high
school-wide so that's not going to sway
a publisher but texas i think texas has
just passed new york to become our
second most popular state it's certainly
up there anyway and so gabler used to be
able to really influence
the state textbook board in texas to
throw out textbooks that
had a different point of view than his
and his was a pretty right-wing point of
view but he also did a really good
public service he also pointed out all
kinds of little bitty factual errors
that publishers made and are still
making uh most famous recently was about
a year or two ago
i think was people connected with gabler
found a textbook that actually claimed
that the korean war was ended when
truman decided to drop the atomic bomb
now truman wasn't even in office when
the korean war was ended
and of course the bomb that was dropped
was dropped on japan a decade earlier
that's a pretty horrible mistake to make
so i share with mr gabler the idea that
we need to critique these textbooks but
i think he and i critique them from
rather different viewpoints he may be
upset with me speaking of that didn't
you cite that something like 22 percent
of the students and you surveyed thought
the vietnam wars between north and south
korea yes isn't that a killer
uh i thought that i had given out the
answer
when you say where you know who fought
in the war of vietnam and 22 say north
and south korea did they tell you why
they thought that
no well
i don't remember i don't remember that i
mean the question in that case was just
a little blank and i didn't ask a why
question so i didn't get it in writing
we did discuss it and
when we discussed the why what what came
up was uh well we never got to that in
in history back to the issue of what is
taught about the war in vietnam nothing
is taught about it so my students ended
up knowing a lot more about the war of
1812 than about the war of uh the war in
vietnam james lowen is our guest and
this is what the cover looks like lies
my teacher told me thank you very much
thank you
[Music]
for calls at area code 202-626-4898
now history on book tv features james
lowen on his book lies across america
but our historic sites get wrong
the former sociology and race relations
professor traveled across the country
researching the history behind
historical monuments houses markers
forts and ships
in a hundred essays he corrects
historical errors and raises questions
about what our nation chooses to
remember and how
his appearance at a washington d.c
bookstore is about an hour
thank you bridget thank you all for
coming out this evening um
people ask me well what caused you to
get so interested in historical
monuments and historic sites
and it possibly grew out of
a little research finding that i
found i guess that's what you do with
findings when i was studying
the
material that i used for lies my teacher
told me i learned that
something like 14 or 15 percent of all
americans ever take a course in history
once they leave high school
and of course since what i
studied was high school history
textbooks and i found that they did a
rather dreadful job and erroneous job in
many cases of teaching american history
that concerned me so
i thought well where do folks learn
about american history if they don't
take it in college of course some folks
don't go to college and if they do they
avoid history many because of their
boring high school history courses well
if you were like my family my dad
stopped the family car at every darn
historical monument and marker that we
ever passed on our family vacation trips
and we stopped at all too many history
museums and historical houses and forts
and ships and so on and i think that's
true across the country that people go
to historic sites and they try to learn
about the past and dad thought that he
was educating us but it seems to me
having done more research on the subject
that often he was miseducating us and i
want to give you some examples tonight
and then we'll have lots of time for
discussion maybe
um
in order to write this book
i seem to have engaged in a masochistic
enterprise just like i did for lives my
teacher told me for lives my teacher
told me i
read intensively 12 american history
high school textbooks
i don't think any previous american had
ever subjected himself to uh to such an
enterprise to such torture it was so
boring this time i attempted to read all
of the state historical markers in the
united states now there's a half a
million historical markers in all
accounting you know the little ones put
up by towns put up by churches put up by
all kinds of things
of state historical markers however
there's not that many it was perhaps a
manageable task except i got defeated by
two states and you might think about the
the character of these states it perhaps
relates to the defeat that i suffered
the first defeat was in texas
texas it turns out has 12 000 historical
markers state historical markers
i pointed out to them that this was
about as many as the rest of the united
states combined and they replied well
yes
implying of course we've had more
history than the rest of the united
states combined
uh
i also did the math i realized that if i
spent exactly one minute reading every
historical marker in texas
the task would take me over six weeks
and that's not giving a lot of thought
to those markers that's just reading
them for a minute so i didn't read them
all in texas although i did end up
reading quite a few of them the other
state that defeated me was new jersey
i went to the state house in trenton i
found the office and the man who's in
charge of historical marcus new jersey
and i said well can i look at your files
and he said well he was quite
embarrassed he said no
about 10 or 15 years ago we lost the
files
so maybe that fits with your image of
new jersey maybe not i don't know uh but
in any case i said to him well if a
snowplow hits one how do you put it back
up and he said well they have to bring
in the pieces or else we don't know what
it said
so the only way to read them all in new
jersey is to drive the entire state and
and i failed to do that although i did
find something in every state to write
an entry about uh this new book lies my
teacher told me is in the form of 100
short entries there's at least one on
every state
showing something that is drastically
wrong with some historical site in that
state and in the district of columbia
let me give you a couple of examples
probably more than a couple um first one
will be from texas and this was a marker
i did read um
you may
it is about the invention of the
airplane in texas
okay now you may be under the
misapprehension that
the airplane was invented by the wright
brothers in kitty hawk north carolina
they flew it for the first time in 1903
but the state of texas has a official
state historical marker
lovely thing in bronze or aluminum or
whatever that says not so
it is in pittsburgh texas a small town
east of dallas and it tells us that in
1902 a whole year before the wright
brothers
the reverend barrell cannon a baptist
minister
got together 25 people who donated a
thousand dollars each and he developed
what he called the ezekiel airship
he named it the ezekiel airship because
he got his plans he said from the book
of ezekiel in the bible
something about a roaring of wings and a
rushing of winds or the other way around
i forget which he said had the complete
blueprints for an airship
so if you go to downtown metropolitan
pittsburgh to this day and you eat in
the only restaurant in downtown
pittsburgh you will see a full-size
model of this airship it's a beautiful
airship done by the optimist club
and i saw it and it has four it is
paddled by if you will it is lifted by
four vertically mounted paddle wheels in
front of and behind the pilot and
there's some wings going out
now paddle
wheels work great on a steamboat because
there's a difference between water and
not water
and so the paddle goes this way and
drives the water backwards and drives
the ship forwards and then it comes back
in the air
i think a moment's reflection will
convince you that in air it doesn't work
so well the paddle goes down and
generates a whole bunch of lift and it
goes this way and generates some forward
motion and unfortunately it then goes
this way and eliminates all the lift and
then it goes this way and eliminates the
forward motion and so this airship i can
guarantee you never got off the ground
um but texas says it did okay well
that's that's kind of funny
um there's another marker in
rural wisconsin that says that here the
automobile was first invented
uh the heck with the mercedes-benz
people and
and uh somebody in france who
probably invented the well it's hard to
say what is the first automobile but i
can tell you it didn't start in
wisconsin and the wisconsin state
historical society is merely embarrassed
by this official state marker and they'd
like to take it down but the people in
the community like it
so they can't get it down
then there's
a marker in idaho that's really
even funnier in one sense but also more
tragic and let me read it to you this is
in alamo idaho
and it's a beautiful marker i have a
picture of it in the book it's a piece
of slate carved in the shape of the
state of idaho which is not a simple
matter we're not talking colorado here
and the
words go as follows
almo idaho
dedicated to the memory of those who
lost their lives in a horrible indian
massacre 1861.
300 immigrants westbound only five
escaped
erected by s d of idaho pioneers 1938
snd is of course the sons and daughters
of idaho pioneers now
this is quite an event
300 dead is actually considerably more
than general george armstrong custer
lost at the battle of the little bighorn
in montana
it turns out however 300 people were not
killed in this horrible massacre 30
people were not killed in this massacre
three people were not killed in this
massacre in fact it's not easy to prove
that something didn't happen it's much
easier to prove positives but
a historian whom i've read the research
of and spent decades of his life proving
that this event never happened at all no
people were ever killed
um this teaches us
that every historical marker every
monument every house museum every
antebellum plantation whatever
is a story of at least two times
in this case it's supposedly a story
about 1861 when this massacre happened
and also it's a story about 1938 when
the marker went up but in this case it's
only a story about 1938 because the
massacre never happened
so that's kind of cute and it really
drills that lesson home
again the idaho state historical society
is not happy with this marker uh they've
tried to get almo to take it down but
the people in almo will not hear of it
because it's the biggest event that ever
happened in almo even though it never
happened in almo and my picture of it
shows it all decorated with christmas
lights uh for christmas time because
they are so happy with it
well
let's see
where do we go from there well i wanted
to emphasize that that there's also
a terminological problem with that
marker and with lots and lots of
historical markers and monuments in that
case
the word massacre of course
and let me ask you a question
how many
dead white people
do you think it takes
to have a massacre
what do you think
shout it out
[Laughter]
the best answer i've heard you're right
zero okay
i've been one-upped um i guess i
shouldn't ask that question directly
after talking about that that marker um
you're right all right i was going to
say that the answer is one because it
turns out there are two historical
markers at least in the united states
one in pennsylvania i believe and one in
florida that talk about a massacre when
one person was killed
in in the florida case they talk about
the bradley massacre which when you read
the fine print
is the killing by the seminole indians
during the seminal wars of a captain
bradley but this gets to be called the
bradley massacre and then we have the
contrary question how many indians
dead indians does it take to have a
massacre
you want to try that one
anybody
what
the answer i i'm not sure i heard you
what oh i'm saying maybe they wouldn't
they don't wouldn't be considered a
massacre no matter how many were killed
that's right that's right
or another way of putting is we don't
know yet
uh in
we have what's called the battle of
horseshoe bend in southern alabama of
the creek indians which killed something
like 900 indians at the cost of i think
a handful if that of
attackers lives the attackers were both
white and choctaw indians too um
but that's the battle the battle of
horseshoe bend and
one of the places that's on the
landscape that's very interesting is at
wounded knee now wounded knee you may
remember 1890 is sometimes called the
last battle of the of the indian west
but it wasn't a battle either
the dakota indians in that area had
surrendered they were under the the
watch under the guard really of the
united states cavalry which had them
surrounded and had two different gatling
guns uh former hotchkiss guns anyway
form of machine gun aimed down at them
and in the disarming process the next
morning
somebody fired a gun we don't know who
fired the first shot i don't think it
hit anybody it may have been an indian
the result was attacks
guns shot down into the into the camp uh
people fled in all directions and and
some very tragic
smaller events happened including the
murder of all kinds of clearly unarmed
civilians women and children in a ditch
very very similar to the milan massacre
almost a century later in vietnam well
that was called on the landscape the
battle of wounded knee and 10 or 15
years ago
someone probably uh
lakota indian replaced the word battle
with the word massacre on both sides of
the sign this is a green and white sign
it's a wooden sinus that used in the
west often he did a perfect job you have
to come right up to it and examine it
carefully to see that any kind of change
was made and the state of south dakota
has left it alone so it now says the
massacre of wounded knee rather than
rather than the battle well there's
other terminology problems that slip by
people um for instance uh discover
you can guess that column we've just
been past a columbus
day
but all over the united states white
folks discover lakes sometimes they're
lakes that have clearly indian names
still implying that maybe
some indian help them visit the lake
rather than discover it but the markers
say they discovered it all of the great
lakes for instance have markers
discovered by whites
and so on
well another another problematic word is
menace and another one is [ __ ] uh
terms like squall lake and squat hits
mountain in arizona are deservedly
offensive to native americans and
another one that i hadn't thought about
until i was doing the research for this
book lies across america is the word
devil as in devil's lake or devil's
tower devil's peaks all across america
whenever you see that word
typically it refers to a site that is a
sacred site of the native people and the
shall we say super christian initial
impli expl
white explorers in the area were
outraged by them and would convert them
then to devil's lake whereas the indians
would con prefer in english spirit lake
and and so on across the across the
country
well i want to say a couple other things
and then we'll take some questions
besides the terms there's also the words
that are left out
and i'll comment briefly on something in
dc since we're in dc we have the
jefferson memorial
not my favorite memorial far from it um
when you go over to the jefferson
memorial
you will see four panels
of jefferson's writings surrounding the
tall
statue of himself
and particularly the third panel is a
problem there's some problems with one
of the other panels but the third panel
is jefferson's writings supposedly on
slavery and on education
and there's three dots all over the
place you know the famous three dots
that will put together two different
sentences and when you actually look at
these sentences it turns out that the
two sentence phrases may be 20 years
apart from each other
maybe
at cross purposes but they're connected
with these dots
ellipses i think is the the official
term for these things
so you never know what's left out and in
my book i try to put back in what's left
out and you you learn then that uh
jefferson was not in favor of abolition
particularly decreasingly so as he
became older was he against slavery and
he particularly was not in favor of
educating slaves or even free black
people so this is a
memorial and it's really a memorial run
by the nps the national park service
that
puts a false image out of jefferson and
even when you go downstairs and you see
the video about jefferson which is a
brand new video
no fault nothing wrong with jefferson
almost everything good that ever
happened in the united states flowed
somehow from from this fount of wisdom
i might say incidentally that the
lincoln memorial is quite different and
has no doubts represents lincoln's words
fairly on its walls and also the video
downstairs is quite effective talks
about the lincoln memorial over time and
not just the high points such as the
famous uh i have a dream speech by
martin luther king but also what might
be some more notorious points such as
the point when
vietnam veterans against the war
took over the memorial and held it for
some hours as a protest against the
vietnam war so it tells that story too
warts and all
so there are some good sites across the
country
uh besides the little dots problem there
are some bigger omissions um i bring out
several in lies across america
one of them for instance is scottsboro
alabama i don't know how many of you
know that what happened in scottsdale
but scottsboro for about 10 years really
was world famous this little town in
alabama was famous for the scottsboro
case often called the scottsboro boys
which were a batch of about eight or
maybe nine uh young african-american
males who were riding the rails who were
you know hobos on the railroad along
with a couple of
white kids in fact several white kids
they got in an argument and apparently
the whites started it actually the black
kids threw rocks at the white kids
because the white kids had started by
throwing rocks at them and the result
was that these black kids were arrested
finally for the rape of two white women
who were on the train
um it's a long story it went on for 10
years people were sentenced to death for
this rape that never happened
incidentally we absolutely again have
proof that the rape never happened but
the uh
defendants were sentenced to death as
many as four different times this case
went up to the u.s supreme court it
became world famous there were protests
about it in latin america in france
you go to scottsboro today there are
four historical markers in downtown
scottsboro including around the
courthouse where this event initially
took place where the first trial
happened
none of them mentions the the event that
made scottsboro famous so this is an
example of what gets left off the
landscape in too many places across
america too many towns are famous for
one major event
but they don't talk about it you can't
learn about it if you just look at the
landscape
well
sometimes it's worse than omission
sometimes the landscape is in direct
denial and so there's various examples
of that in lies across america i'll
mention just two right now and they both
have to do with sexual orientation uh if
you visit the willa cather homestead in
nebraska where she grew up
she is an obviously lesbian writer
according to
all kinds of uh right uh
commentators and professors of english
and her biographer and you ask was she
lesbian you got a flat denial no she was
not despite the fact that the bookstore
carries books arguing that of course she
was
and i personally went to buchanan's
house that is james buchanan not pat
president james buchanan's house in in
lancaster pennsylvania
and asked after the tour was he gay
quote no he was not buchanan was gay or
at least buchanan was homosexual there's
some people like you shouldn't use the
word gay in the 19th century because
it's anachronistic i don't know about
that uh and in both of these cases uh
buchanan and cather it mattered that is
it mattered to their work
in the case of buchanan for instance
his long-term lover
was the senator from alabama
a right-wing pro-slavery senator who in
fact owned slaves
and
uh who influenced buchanan surely
politically because buchanan became a
member of in fact even a tool of the
pro-slavery wing of the democratic party
throughout the 1840s and 50s
even though he came from lancaster
county which is full of mennonites and
quakers some of the most anti-slavery
people in the country and his own church
which was a presbyterian church
disbarred him from fellowship because of
his
pro-slavery views so how do you explain
this well the the buchanan homestead
doesn't try to they simply say uh when i
asked them how did he feel about slavery
they said he was against it all of the
people in this area were well they're
right about all of the people in the
area they're wrong about buchanan
they're in denial
well let's see finally a couple of other
uh errors these are not exactly errors
of denial they're errors of commission
sins of commission uh i think i'll just
deal with with one today and that is
confederate monuments
um
confederate monuments are all over the
place of course all across america north
as well as south
my entry on confederate monuments and
memorials is one of the longer entries
in the book
and i cite it in helena montana
now you might say where there's a
beautiful fountain and big thing and it
says uh for our confederate dead
and you might say gee i didn't know
there were any confederate dead in
helena montana and of course there
weren't any confederate dead in helena
montana in fact there weren't any union
dead in helena montana because during
the civil war there was no montana i
mean montana was invented as a territory
in 1864 after all and it was still
indian country as late as 1876 when
george armstrong custer had a little
trouble with the indians up at what's
called the battle of a little bighorn
and that was in montana
so how come there's a monument to our
confederate dead in helena montana well
again we have to look at when it went up
and it went up in about 1913
and at that time that's between maybe
1890 and 1920
what many historians called the nadir
or a low point of american history
well the low point of race relations in
american history and during this time
the confederacy really won the civil war
and they wanted in several ways one of
the ways they wanted is they won it on
the landscape and they put up
confederate monuments all across the
country to indicate this
they also won it in terms of terminology
and it became during that time period
and to some extent to this day the war
between the states it was never called
the war between the states while it was
being fought it was called the civil war
or sometimes the war of the rebellion
and that's why the confederates were
called rebels
they also won it in that time period by
defining what it was about and it was
supposedly about states rights which it
wasn't
anyway
it isn't just helena montana then
another example of this problem
is right here or almost right here just
north of here uh the county just north
of here is montgomery county maryland
and at the courthouse is a rather
beautiful confederate monument it's in
rockville it says something like uh
do not forget to love the thin gray line
okay so this is a statement in 1910 or
1915 we must remember and love the
confederacy in maryland now maryland did
not secede
uh
maryland in fact this county in maryland
probably sent more
people by far to the u.s armies than to
the confederate armies but they are
forgotten on the landscape and another
example of that is kentucky uh the
entire state of kentucky did not secede
you will remember it did send 30 000 or
so troops to the confederacy but it's at
90 000 troops to the u.s
okay today it has 73
civil war monuments
two of them are for the union and 71
for the confederacy so the confederacy
now holds kentucky which was never able
to hold during the civil war
and it makes a difference and i argue in
lies across america that this is not
just oh who cares about those old
monuments anyway it makes a difference
it makes a difference to people's
conduct even today or just yesterday
in kentucky
well i want to close by asking you guys
a question
in all of the united states
who do you think
would get the most markers and monuments
in one state i mean would it be abraham
lincoln in illinois say
or
who do you think
anybody
jefferson in virginia
thomas jefferson in virginia that makes
sense no
it's a trick question of course but
that's a good guess no
any other guesses
what about george washington george
washington in virginia that's even a
better guess because he gets all these
monuments that say you know markers
anyway george washington spent the night
here you know and so on um
let me digress in fact for a minute and
tell you that the most hilarious george
washington monument or marker
comes from new york state
and
i think i'll read it to you since he's
come up it's very very short
and then i'll tell you who does get the
most markers and monuments in one state
here we go
this is
way up in the town of alabama new york
which is up in northern new york in
genesee county and the marker says put
up in 1932 quote fording place on grand
central trail
said to have been used by george
washington during the french and indian
war so here we have a place across a
creek that george washington walked
and he did it turns out
but it wasn't that george washington
it was a different george washington who
furthermore turns out to have been a
native american
who lived up there and he walked across
this creek which i think and they've
this has been brought to the attention
of the state of new york they leave the
marker up this opens up an entire new
area for historical markers if you think
about it i mean it turns out that there
is right now in
seattle four different people at least
named john adams the second president
okay so they could have historical
markers it just wouldn't be that john
adams right uh in central mississippi
there's a professor called john quincy
adams and he's a professor of political
science even so he could have a marker
you know john quincy adams got divorced
here you know or whatever
lyndon b johnson lives in southgate
california
i looked him up
um
and and so on there are
at least two dozen george washington's
alive in the united states today
so we can have all kinds of new
historical markers that uh that we
haven't ever thought of you know george
washington indicted for income tax
evasion here in in reno nevada or
whatever you know okay if there is one
in reno i take it back i didn't mean it
all right
who gets the most historical markers it
isn't washington in virginia it isn't
robert e lee in virginia which would be
a
sadder choice but and it isn't jefferson
davis that would be in mississippi say
that would be a sad choice but it is
worse than any of those actually it is
the person who gets the most historical
markers and monuments in one state is
none other than nathan bedford forest in
tennessee now who was nathan bedford
forrest he was of course the first
national leader of the ku klux klan
during reconstruction
before then during the civil war he was
the confederate general whose men
committed the notorious fort pillow
massacre killing surrendered troops
black and white at fort pillow on the
mississippi river in tennessee that's
one of his historical markers and of
course it denies that there was a
massacre
before the civil war he was a slave
trader and he even brought
slaves directly from africa in the 1850s
to the united states although that trade
had been outlawed by an act of congress
in 1808
so this is the man who gets more
historical markers and monuments than
anyone else in the united states this is
why sometimes i
talk in this book about we live in a
landscape of white supremacy uh one of
the markers is so inconsequential it
actually says
forest rested here i mean even george
washington had to spend the night or
afford a stream you know do something
more than just rest
um
it's it's absurd
well i'm going to close with
a little
encore i guess you haven't applauded yet
but
an encore about toppling uh my book
closes with an appendix that lists 20
candidates for toppling um markers and
monuments that i suggest are so
outrageous that something needs to be
done about them i do suggest toppling in
quotes that is that we can do something
more interesting than just remove them
uh we can take them to a museum and put
appropriate labels on them like this
almo
massacre monument in idaho i'd hate to
see that just destroyed it deserves to
go into a into a museum somewhere where
it becomes a commentary on 1938 it has
nothing to teach us about 1861.
well toppling
i tried to find out what is the most
toppled monument in the united states
now americans are all fired up for
toppling when it takes place in poland
you know or russia these topplings of
lenin and stalin and the kgb heads and
so on have met with nothing but our
approval but in terms of toppling in the
united states
the last toppling we really talk about
is the toppling of the statue of king
george iii
in manhattan which happened during the
revolution and he not only got toppled
he got melted down by the good ladies of
connecticut into uh bullets for the
patriot cause at least that's apparently
what happened
um
what is the most toppled statue in the
united states
i think it's
hay market the statue to the haymarket
event you remember the haymarket event
this was in chicago in 1886
led by socialists and anarchists these
workers were demonstrating for that
far-out left-wing concept called the
eight-hour day now ironically illinois
already had a law guaranteeing the
eight-hour day had been passed in 1869
by the republicans but it wasn't being
enforced so they wanted it enforced so
they demonstrated in a huge parade on
may 1st 1886 and this is where we get
may 1st as may day or labor day
throughout the world everywhere but in
the united states and canada where labor
day is in the fall
you can think about that one for a
minute but
they had this huge parade a day or so
later they had another demonstration
this time at the mccormick reaper plant
which was now international harvester
which was a huge plant and which was on
strike
and during this demonstration police got
upset fired into the crowd to kill two
people
that's not haymarket yet though the
haymarket event was the next day may 4th
1886 when a crowd of people assembled in
haymarket square and
listened to speeches condemning the
murder of the two people the day before
at the mccormick reaper plant
the speeches went on and on as speeches
will do and a light rain began to fall
and it became about 10 pm and the mayor
visited the scene and he declared it
peaceable by then only a few hundred
three or four hundred workers remained
and so he went to bed and shortly
thereafter a lieutenant of police
appeared on the scene with
i used to know this i think 150 or so
policemen behind him and declared the
scene unpeaceable and he raised his
right hand and he said in the name of
the people of illinois i command you
dispersing peace
and just then a bomb was thrown amongst
the police blew some of them up and they
opened fire killing some other police
incidentally but also killing some
workers and by the time and everybody
scattered in all directions and that was
the haymarket riot it's called a
haymarket affair
seven policemen lay dead
about seven workers were not quite sure
lay dead and there were dozens of
wounded on each side
well three years later
chicago erected a statue commemorating
the event and it was a statue of a big
burly policeman with his hand up like
this and around the base it said
in the name of the people of illinois i
command peace
okay well this statue stood in haymarket
square for the next 11 years and during
this time the the workers weren't really
excited about it because they said this
is a little one-sided you know we'd like
a statue too we lost seven of our people
and chicago wouldn't allow them to
commemorate the event anywhere within
the city limits so they eventually built
a rather beautiful statue at waldheim
cemetery in a western suburb just
outside the city but inside the city
nothing so the statue of the policemen
took a lot of abuse from workers and
finally in 1900 the police said well
we're tired of cleaning it up all the
time and having it broken and painted
paint on it and so on we want it moved
so they moved it to union park
and there it sat until the 42nd
anniversary to the day
of the original event
and on that day a streetcar
left the track trundled into the park
hit the statue and toppled it
so that's the first toppling now you
might say that was an act of god but i
found that somebody did an interview
with the conductor
and he said i got so tired of him
standing with his damn arm up
so apparently it wasn't an active god
they moved the statue to a safer part of
union park
and i don't call that a toppling that's
a removal but and there it stood until
the 1950s at this point the police said
look
seven of our brethren
gave their lives in haymarket square we
want the statue back
so they put it back by this time
haymarket square had been obliterated by
the jfk expressway but they found out
they made a kind of little semi-circle
place for it and they put it back
overlooking the expressway
then in 1968
yes in 1968 a group called the
weathermen remember them uh some of you
will that's a radical offshoot of
students from a democratic society they
blew up the statue toppled it they were
upset with chicago police because of
events in 1968 including the the their
behavior during the uh democratic
primary at a democratic national
convention
so they toppled the statue
that's the second toppling mayor daley a
different daily from today's mayor daley
but they're always made a daily in
chicago was outraged he said this was an
event that that will
outrage any right-thinking chicagoan and
he had the legs recast and the statue
put back up
one year later to the day
the same group now calling itself the
weather underground
so it's not sexist blew it up again blew
one of the legs onto the expressway in
fact
toppling it mayor daley was outraged
again that's the third toppling and they
recast the statue again now chicago
mounted a seven day a week 24 hour a day
police guard and i submit to you that in
the entire history of law enforcement
this has to be the most boring
assignment to spend eight hours watching
a statue i think even the donuts won't
help so after a few months of this
some of the columnists in chicago
pointed out that the weatherman had
immobilized a total of five policemen
because that's what it takes to mount a
such a such a watch and a squad car and
it was costing the city thousands and
thousands of dollars so they moved the
statue i have a wonderful picture in the
book of the statue with his arm up being
tilted a little bit and lifted up by a
helicopter or a crane i think i forget
which uh and they moved it indoors to
where they thought it would be safe in
central police headquarters okay they
left the base
and i went to visit it there just four
or five years ago
only to find that it had been moved
again and the reason was as the sergeant
explained to me uh they realized that in
this era of unabombers and such that
instead of making the statue safe by
putting it in the police headquarters
they may have made themselves unsafe so
they put the statue back outdoors but it
is surrounded on all four sides by the
chicago police training academy and it's
in an atrium
and in order to see it you have to do as
i did sign yourself in at the desk get
escorted to the cafeteria get let
through the cafeteria and into the
atrium and then you can take its picture
which i did
okay
i pointed out to them that it's still
vulnerable to helicopter attack but
well the base
still stood and i had heard correctly as
it turned out that a nearby parishioner
had used it why let it go to waste
for a statue of the blessed virgin mary
and so i went to take a picture of her
only to find when i got there that she
was gone toppled that's the fourth
toppling and that the base had been
obliterated so it could never be used
again
now why i talked with the official in
charge
and it turned out that he was
embarrassed by it all
and you might think well jesus there's
statues of our lady all over the world
and there's certainly many statues of
the madonna in chicago
but it did turn out that in all the
world this was the only statue of the
blessed virgin mary that said in the
name of the people of illinois i command
peace
so that's why it was
an embarrassment and that's why it was
toppled
well that ended on a lighter note i'm
done thank you for your attention like
to hear from from you from with some
questions
[Applause]
yes i have a question in the bastion of
the white supremacist behavior in this
country um
what interesting um landmarks have you
come across dedicated to the
african-american experience in this
country
interesting question um
i've tried to decide what states have
the best historical markers
and i've concluded that there's three
states that stand out
michigan pennsylvania and alabama and
with regard to treatment of
african-american subjects and what's
sometimes called african-american
history although i would argue it is
history
um the two states that are the best are
pennsylvania and alabama
now pennsylvania is because
of one man and it's interesting in fact
how people can influence the landscape
and i want to suggest that anybody uh
hearing my voice watching me speak uh
can influence the landscape in this case
it was a man named charles blockley a
historian an african-american professor
at temple university who got a grant and
argued for and got up
some 65 or 75 historical markers that
particularly treat african-american
history
including some tough subjects in and
around philadelphia but in alabama it's
a matter of state policy
and it turns out that the director of
tourism in alabama for at least the last
10 years has been african-american
alabama says black folks spend the same
color of money as everybody else and we
want to
have them come and see and what do we
have to offer we have a lot of history
so there's some terrific historical
markers in alabama
and having seen them on the landscape
myself for instance there's good markers
for the church at which martin luther
king preached which is right opposite
the state house
in downtown montgomery there's good
markers for the events in selma alabama
there's just pretty good markers
treating the civil rights era in
particular
so i asked one of the people in charge
of historical markers in alabama have
you had any trouble because of any of
these markers has anybody opposed them
thinking that you know some of the
leftover ku klux klan strata might might
have given them some trouble
he said only one and the one that they
had had trouble with was a historical
marker that on one side said
a whole bunch of stuff about the
surrender of
uh the state capitol montgomery to
general wilson the united states cavalry
leader who had an enormous cavalry force
and who took it
took montgomery in 1865
and
the marker says that on one side and it
used to say on the other side a
biography of general wilson and this
biography read kind of like a phone book
i mean it said general i forgot his
first name so-and-so wilson uh b you
know born such and such a date um
graduated wpt
1854 whenever it was you know and then
gave his career in terms of his
promotions in previous battles
there was the word extraordinary at one
point but otherwise it was just a
biography you know with almost no
it was the biography that bothered
and the people that bothered were the
sons of confederate veterans
today
and i said well how come they said well
they just were bothered by the idea that
we would put up the biography of a union
general it's as if it's a role model so
they actually forced or prevailed upon
the state to move that marker to the
edge of town to where the surrender
happened
and at the state capitol where the
marker had been they put it back up the
side that said talked about the
surrender of montgomery on both sides so
it has the same text on both sides it
was the biography that bothered people
no trouble with the civil rights
memorials no trouble with the the
monuments that treat black subjects so
you never know what's going to give the
trouble again in pennsylvania i asked um
have you had any trouble with any of
your markers they have a tough new
marker for instance about a place in
philadelphia that used to be a slave
mart now the slave sales are almost
never talked about on the landscape we
have all these plantations that are very
nice everybody lived happy lives on the
plantation but the idea of buying and
selling slaves you can't make that seem
nice even though the plantation wasn't
either but so here we have this tough
marker no problem the problem that gay
that the markers are in pennsylvania
that the market that's a problem
it's the markers that's about little
league
because there's two different people
that claim that they invented little
league in the town of williamsport
pennsylvania and one of them gets credit
on the marker and the other one keeps
threatening to blow it up or do
something bad to it
good question are there any other
questions yes
i keep seeing arguments among people
about whether there is a secret code for
horse statues i don't know if you
covered that or not yes i don't talk
about it but i know the answer to that
uh the assertion is something like this
if they've got all four feet on the
ground fine if they've got one foot
raised then the person was wounded or
something like that and if they've got
two feet raised the person was killed at
that at that site right
yeah
it turns out it's not true
um the sculptures did what they wanted
to do
so we've got lots of examples of folks
with i don't know if there's very many
horses with three feet raised and and i
can pretty much guarantee that's not my
four feet raised but
the sculptors did what they wanted to do
let me just segue to that really briefly
um sculptors do what they want to do on
some other matters too
um
one of the ways that women get left off
the landscape a subject we haven't
talked about but that is taught treated
in in lies across america but one of the
ways they get lost left off is that
female horses get left off
now i submit to you that in warfare a
mayor and a stallion being ridden by
generals or whatever do pretty much the
same thing we can't argue that them
women just weren't presidents you know
like the men were and so it's fair
enough that they get left off uh and so
there are famous examples and one of
them is right here in washington dc and
he's pictured in
the book general winfield scott is up is
in scott circle of course we have uh
people on horseback all over washington
dc
and scott's favorite horse was a mare
and in this case the sculptor
made the horse a mare
but in this case the family was outraged
and they said well it's just not manly
to have him on a mare
so the sculpture said well okay and he
added the appropriate
accoutrements and i took a picture of
all this with the setting sun behind it
in the west so that the accoutrements
are visible
the most hilarious case of this anywhere
in america has to be
the case of general
john
i forget his middle name john morgan
in louisville
because
john morgan's favorite horse was again a
mayor bess
and
in this case the sculptor wouldn't have
it i think he was italian and he didn't
think it was manly to have the the
general on a female horse so he made the
horse a male so you've got this horse
with
everything a male horse should have and
the the
basis
uh general john
h or whatever it was morgan and his best
b-e-s-s
and it turns out that there's a long
tradition of the fraternity kids at the
nearby university of kentucky
painting bess's
unfortunate male appendages bright neon
colors throughout the the school year
and there's a poem been written about
this and all of this is in my book
i even add to the let's see if i can
find what i add to the
to the poem quickly enough
it's just doggerel anyway and any
reasonable person here we are though
okay
the poem goes so sorrow comes to
bluegrass men like darkness or them
falls for well we know gentlemen should
show respect for a lady's balls
and
and i add this other lines but i add
this quatrain how can women take their
place in history in due course when
monuments don't even let a lady be a
horse
yes um in the first book licensing
teacher told me you talked about john
brown and i wanted a few because i
haven't gone to the john brown house in
harper's fair but i've heard that
there's some interesting things there
like i think there's like a plaque from
the daughters of the confederacy he's
one of the slaves who is responsible yes
turning into i wish you could you could
talk about that yes um
john brown is treated on the landscape
in several places in america and of
course john brown did stuff in several
places in america
i don't treat harper's ferry in lies
across america and the reason i don't is
because harper's ferry i think is a
pretty good site and i'm thinking about
writing some kind of sequel
to lies across america and in a way it
might even be a sequel to lies my
teacher told me that might be called
something like surprises on them
on the landscape places that actually
get history right and harpers ferry
might be one of them uh at harpers fair
if you go there right now you see what i
call the duel of the plaques you see
three different plaques one of them is
the plaque you're talking about a plaque
put up by the united daughters of the
confederacy who put up of course the
monument to the confederacy in helena
montana and who have put up errors on
the landscape all across the united
states well at harpers ferry they put up
a plaque that celebrates haywood
shepherd who was the free
african-american or quasi-free who was
one of the impossibly the first people
killed by john brown's men in the
seizure of the armory at harpers ferry
what is now west virginia in 1859
well this was a tragedy and too bad it's
probably the only
african-american that the united
daughters of the confederacy celebrate
anywhere across america and of course
they're celebrating him and his death
for ideological reasons because this
shows how outrageous john brown was well
for many years this plaque was covered
over with plywood by the national park
service but now they've uncovered it
partly because of pressure from the sons
of confederate veterans but they have
put next to it their own plaque that
interprets this plaque and tells more
about the event and quotes w b du bois
and does a pretty good job of telling
some history so that's the second plaque
and the third plaque is put up on the
armory itself built into the armory and
it's put up by storer college which was
a black college that deliberately chose
to locate at harpers ferry partly
because uh they honored what john brown
had tried to do there uh it went out of
business after the 1954 uh brown versus
board of education supreme court
desegregation decision but when it was
in business back in about 1918 or so
they put up a plaque
that is sacred to the memory of john
brown and his 18 or 23 depending on how
you count them followers and it goes on
to say uh positive things about john
brown so you've got the positive the
negative and the interpretive by the
national park service i think that's
great you know i think there's a lot of
history going on there
i do have another entry about john brown
that treats john brown's farm and i
won't tell you about it i would suggest
you look for it in the book
because john brown's farm up in upstate
new york where he is buried now where
john brown's body lies does a terrible
disservice to his name and it's a real
shame
one more question what's the quality of
sort of the historicity or the
historical scholarship in in these
various state places is it is it just
political jobs or are there real
scholars at work trying to write this
stuff it varies a lot uh by state
and it's gotten better
uh the disastrous historical markers
went up in the 1930s and maybe the 40s
and even into the 50s and 60s
but in about the 70s and i think it was
partly
a result of the civil rights movement
but not just about race relations but in
the 70s and 80s they tended to appoint
people who if not historians at least
cared about history and many of the
states now have a commission that
and it's just a one-person office maybe
or a two-person office but then there's
a commission uh or a board that has to
vet and approve any new historical
marker and so you do have to prove these
things you know you have to the the
airplane in texas wouldn't get up today
because you can't prove that it ever
flew
um they're not yeah they're not doing
much of a job of taking them down
although there is some movement in that
regard
in virginia i have a late entry it's
kind of a theoretical entry i call
snowplow revisionism because in virginia
they had a terrible marker
talked about last indian outrage and
didn't tell much history but it
certainly conveyed that we were outraged
by those indians and it got hit by
snowplow a few years ago or by a mowing
machine there's a controversy about what
hit it
and when they put it back up it didn't
say last indian outrage anymore now it
said last indian settler conflict which
was much more accurate and the paragraph
below was much more accurate and told
much more history too and virginia turns
out has a program they don't even always
wait for snowplows
to replace some of their worst markers
the same thing is going on in kansas
colorado is talking about such a program
and may have it in place by now so there
is some movement by these professionals
to get better market tax up but
nonetheless it's still a matter of
pressure on them and i know this for
instance because in michigan
there's and i already said that michigan
has some of the best markers in the u.s
they have a good marker for uh a strike
at gm for instance that it's a tough
issue in michigan they have a good
marker for uh malcolm x who grew up in
uh lansing michigan uh but they have a
terrible marker for
uh orville hubbard who was the mayor of
dearborn michigan and the most
outrageous segregationist north of the
mason-dixon line possibly one of the
most outrageous in all of the u.s
he was a mayor for like 25 years or so
and his marker doesn't mention anything
about what he was famous for instead it
says he was famous for good government
and for
punctual trash collection and and so on
and at the time the marker supervisor
was an african-american woman and i
interviewed her and i said how come how
could this market be so bad and she said
well it's all we could get up
so even in a state that does a
professional job there's still a
question of the pressures on them and i
think they need to hear from the rest of
us
so that they uh
put up some more accurate markers and
revise some of these terrible ones
again thank you i hope you all buy this
hilarious and deeply sad book and i'll
sign any copies that you do buy and
there's also a few copies of lies my
teacher told me around in the store
thanks a lot
[Applause]
and you can come up and talk to me even
if you don't buy it
if you have any suggestions on books
that give like a concise um sort of
summary of
sort of debunking myths about us
involvement
in their american foreign posse in the
middle east or around the world yes i do
um one chapter of lies my teacher told
me uh treats that kind of stuff it's a
chapter called watching big brother and
it looks at what the government does and
what we say about the government but
much bigger than that is um
a book by jonathan clinton
called
um
but it's called endless enemies
and you can hear right from the title
what it's about almost uh and quitting
he's very interesting writer because
he's not anti-american and he's
certainly not anti-capitalism but he's
very much anti the antics if you will of
our government in fomenting
assassination attempts and so on around
the world so i'd start with that book
okay and then when do you like how do
you do your ongoing research like it
seems like you're someone who's
interested in learning the truth about
yeah things i don't know how to current
events i keep reading all the time you
know um i know how i did the research
yeah and and books books like whitney's
you know um the web but you have to
check stuff out yeah you can't just
believe everything but
james lowen's previous book lies my
teacher told me won the american book
award and the oliver cromwell cox award
for anti-racist scholarship
his latest book lies across america is
published by the new press
talk on the senate kept it from even
ever coming up for a vote in the senate
and you may remember that the senate
passed a resolution apologizing for that
this summer and the movement to do that
was led by two southern senators
[Music]
thank you very much patricia bernstein
the book is called the first waco horror
the lynching of jesse washington and the
rise of the naacp thank you
sundown towns use policemen fire bricks
and signs to force blacks out of the
suburbs and into the ghettos
some of them are still in existence
today according to sociology professor
james lowen
he chronicles their history in the new
book sundown towns
this is an hour ten minutes
it is my pleasure to welcome james lowen
today to discuss his new book which is
called sundown towns
dr lowen is also the author of the
best-selling book lies my teacher told
taught me
which is loved by teachers and students
alike because it takes aim at the
sanitized textbooks used to misrepresent
history
his new book sundown towns is the result
of years of research into the formation
and the persistence of white only towns
i've often wondered about towns with
names like whitesboro or white city
but the story of codified white
supremacy in american towns and suburbs
is long and harrowing and amazingly well
hidden
this book is a remarkable contribution
to the account of institutionalized
racism in the united states i'm glad to
note that the book is reviewed very
favorably by laura wexler in today's
washington post please welcome dr james
lowen
[Applause]
thanks virginia thanks to all of you for
coming out i want to say just a word
about uh
independent book stories in general and
this one in particular um i've actually
become an educated person by coming to
all these free events here and um
i want to
thank you all
at the bookstore for them and i want to
also say that i do make it my policy
usually uh i try to when i come to a
free event like this uh book talk to buy
a book not necessarily the book that's
being sold that evening but some book
before leaving because although it's a
free event the bookstore still needs to
make money somehow you know
this evening however
i would suggest that you would want to
get my book
you were supposed to laugh just when i
said this evening however you're not as
sharp as i was hoping but anyway um
i also want to say something about uh
this book just to get started um
i actually think it's the most important
book i've written and i've written seven
maybe i don't know maybe eight
lies my teacher told me has done awfully
well and it keeps on selling and i'm
very happy i wrote it and i think it's a
very important book
but lies my teacher told me makes uh
people amazed who are not historians or
haven't really studied it closely it
actually even amazes historians out of
their period but any historian who knows
about for instance the civil war and
reads what i say about it in lies my
teacher told me is not amazed okay but
this book sundown towns is actually
going to i think amaze everyone
sociologists and historians and so on
because in it i think i have discovered
and and published for the world a bunch
of new stuff stuff that's never been
written by anybody before and i think
it's actually disgusting as well as
amazing that it's never been written by
anybody before in fact while i was doing
the research for this book which took me
five five years of doing almost nothing
else i kept expecting to find stuff
about this subject
and and i found virtually nothing at all
okay so i want to take you all on a uh
journey of discovery because
i have to persuade you
of the magnitude of the phenomenon that
sundown towns purports and i think
correctly purports to have discovered
all right and if i just tell it to you
i'm not sure you'll believe me because i
didn't believe it i had you know i had
to find it i had to be convinced of it
so i want to take you on the same
journey that i made um
in the process of taking that journey
we're going to answer the basic
questions which are what are sundown
towns where are they how many are there
when did they get created um how did
they get created how do they get
maintained what difference do they make
anyway and finally what should we do
about them
well what is a sundown town a sun
downtown is a community that for decades
and some of them still do it
kept out people of color particularly
after african americans now some of them
kept out especially in the west chinese
americans or japanese americans i
discovered two towns in nevada that
sounded a whistle at six p.m every night
to tell native americans or american
indians they must be gone
i discovered one town in california and
one in colorado and i'm sure i've missed
probably dozens more that kept out
mexican americans
there are many many many suburbs
especially and also some beach
communities and some resort mountain
communities that kept out jewish
americans okay
and all of those things are covered in
some downtowns but the great target was
and to some degree remains
african-americans okay
they get their title because many of
these towns in the midwest in oregon in
california
in the across the north except the
northeast and the east
put
signs at their city limits typically
saying quote [ __ ] don't let the sun go
down on you in
manitowoc for instance which is a town a
city actually of about 30 000 in
wisconsin on lake michigan and which did
have such signs or i might have said
ashland oregon or taft california or
pekin illinois or miacca city florida
all of which did have such signs okay
not all sundown towns had such signs of
course
many of them did not
almost no sundown suburbs had such signs
and i need to tell you that some down
well let's get let's skip ahead to uh
when did these towns come into being
they came into being between 1890 and
1940 for the most part there's some
seats in the middle here a couple over
here um
they came into being between 1890 and
1940. they weren't always this way
one of the things i learned while doing
the research for this book
is that in america between 1863 and 1890
african americans went everywhere all
right
they got into every county in indiana
but one every county in montana but one
all over the place okay chinese
americans did the same thing this
actually surprised me even more i mean
of course i grew up and until recently
kind of thought of chinese americans as
creatures of the big city they live in
chinatown in san francisco do they not
chinatown in this city chinatown in
chicago and so on well yes they do now
uh i thought this was just natural of
course when a sociologist says natural
he puts quotation marks around it by
which he really means deep in our
culture so that i didn't think about it
all right um after all they had left a
big city most chinese came here from
canton china uh over 90 percent that's a
big city they came on ocean-going
vessels of course and they mostly came
into a big city san francisco the
largest city in the west at the time
but no that's not the case they came
into san francisco and they went all
over the place they were in every county
in wyoming they were in in 1890 uh well
excuse me in 1870 and into the 1880s
they were in every county of idaho in
fact they were 20 of the population of
idaho which is one of our most rural
states then and now okay
but then between about 1884 and 1900 the
chinese undergo a vast retreat
and it's kind of a prologue to what i'm
going to talk about happened to black
folks
that is they get pressured out of in
fact they get driven out of every county
in wyoming except one they get driven
out of almost every county and community
in idaho more than 50 towns in
california drive out to chinese even
large cities like tacoma washington
drive out their entire chinese
population send them on two big boats
back to san francisco so that's how
chinese ended up in chinatown okay
well i had the same misconception about
african americans i grew up in decatur
illinois which is a city of 60 to 90 000
depending on which census you look at
in the center of illinois and it had a
substantial black black population about
15 20 percent um i knew that
and i it never occurred to me that all
the little towns around decatur
uh monticello niantic uh dalton city i'm
sure these names mean a lot to you um
i knew they were all white it never
occurred to me they were all white on
purpose i mean i thought
i'd rather live in decatur it has motion
picture theaters you know and and
grocery stores and things and um and
that's what black folks would rather do
i'll tell you about how my mind got
changed in in just a few minutes
so between 1863
and when refugees from the civil war and
when thing uh slavery basically started
ending everywhere the united states army
controlled
between 1863 and 1890 black folks went
everywhere i mentioned they ended up in
every county in indiana but one every
county of montana but one and so on
then beginning in 1890 from 1890 to 1940
commenced what historians call the nader
of race relations
and
nato of course means
low point right it's an english language
word we're not talking ralph here
n-a-d-i-r um
the opposite of zenith i guess
the nader of race relations is the
period 1890 to 1940. i have a whole
chapter on it in here in which i call it
the nader gestation i don't know what i
call it something like the nader
gestation period for uh sundown towns
what happened during the nader was in
the south
uh the real end of reconstruction now of
course reconstruction formally ended in
about 1876 but it
black folks were still voting in the
south uh there was still possibility for
black white coalitions the the
democratic party had no lock on the
south at that point of course remember
the democrats were the party of of white
supremacy in the 19th century um and
well into the 20th century into the
1920s called themselves the white man's
party this is hard to remember sometimes
because exactly 41 years ago the two
parties flip-flopped on this matter but
in the 19th century the democrats were
the party of white supremacy and they
ended reconstruction by force and fraud
in 1876 but they didn't really end uh
the voting of black folks they didn't
really end the possibility for
interracial cooperation in the south
that ended in 1890 with mississippi's
constitution of 1890 which removed
blacks from citizenship took away the
right their right to vote
and the united states did nothing even
though it directly contravened the 14th
and 15th amendments to the constitution
so every other southern state and states
as far away as oklahoma followed suit by
1907. okay that's one of the reasons we
date the nader exactly at 1890. there
are a couple of others but
i won't go into them right now
but what i've learned doing this
research
is that
the period of reconstruction while it
only applied legally to the south it
applied ideologically to the whole
country
that and actually nobody's written about
that either or hardly anybody um
in the north especially in republican
communities or communities with
considerable numbers of quakers or
unitarians or presbyterians or
united church of christ or
congregationalists or methodists and
these are a lot of communities you know
these towns actually many of them
developed a welcoming attitude towards
black folks let me give you just one
example
fond du lac wisconsin
even during the civil war i think it was
in late 1863 or early 64. a train comes
to fond du lac burying one or two cars
passenger cars full of black folks along
with a white chaplain from the united
states army who had
been assigned to cairo illinois which is
down at the bottom of illinois where
which was kind of a staging ground for
the civil war in the mississippi valley
and a bunch of refugees uh black
refugees and white refugees for that
matter and wound up in carroll so he
helped this carload or so get to fond du
lac and it was the biggest event in town
everybody comes down to see these folks
and haven't been very many black folks
in wisconsin at that point and folks
sign up for them i could use a hand i'm
putting in a new orchard i could use two
you know and so on before they got
parceled out to folks they all got uh
supper and spent the night in the local
hotel downtown and then the next day
they they went off and commenced living
in fond du lac okay
and so it was kind of i think it was
kind of like and not just in fond du lac
the phenomenon that we saw in the 1960s
and early 1970s when colleges actually
across the north and the south uh
started competing for uh african
americans i mean my college for instance
carleton college i actually went to
college with the fifth black person ever
to graduate from carleton college and
carlton had been in existence 102 years
when i graduated so that you can do the
math that's one every 21 years or so
okay um but i graduated in 1964. right
at that point carlton and yale and
university of maryland for that matter
started competing in the late 60s for
african-americans and and certainly
opening up their gates to them and i
think uh many many towns especially
republican towns opened up to black
folks across the north
but then in the 1890s 1890 to 1940 this
nader this reaction this terrible period
sets in
another reason we dated 1890 is because
in 1890 the united states senate failed
to pass by a single vote
the fair elections bill now this bill is
kind of
similar to the 1965 voting rights act
not as good but not a bad bill it would
have helped publicize the fact that
blacks were increasingly finding it
difficult to vote fairly and freely in
the south it would have penalized the
south for in interfering with uh black
light or anybody's right to vote and so
on and it passed the house and it failed
by a single vote in the senate of course
president benjamin harrison the
republican president would have signed
it into law well after defeating this
bill the democrats did their usual trick
which was to tar the republicans to
accuse them of being quote black
republicans unquote of being nothing but
a bunch of quote [ __ ] lovers unquote
the republicans had faced this before
what they had done up until then was to
say you're darn right somebody ought to
be standing up for these folks it's an
outrage what you people are doing down
the south on election day and this needs
to stop
but they made a new response after 1890.
their new response was no we ain't
and you remember what the charge was
no we aren't
so at that point the republicans gave up
on civil rights for everybody and that's
another reason then and democrats had
never had any use for it at all so now
there was no political or or any remedy
for the the bereft quality of african
americans and african-american civil
rights in america
well across the united states then
between 1890 and 1940 as i discovered in
doing the research for sundown towns
community after community drove out its
black population and i've uncovered
scores of little race riots
we know we've always known of a few of
the big ones like i think was 1917 east
st louis 1919 chicago 1919 washington dc
uh only recently has the memory of the
one in tulsa oklahoma i think 1921 been
recovered we know of that one now but
i'm talking about scores more the race
riot in pinkneyville illinois for
instance which i haven't even dated for
sure but i think was 1928 in which the
black community was expelled never to
return and it's an eerie sense that you
have i've been in the community in
pinkneyville called the black hills
now i got to tell you it's not called
the black hills because it looks like
south dakota okay it is hilly mildly
hilly i mean we're talking illinois
after all
it's called the black hills because this
was the black community
since 1928 it has been all white okay
and
in some downtowns there's a portfolio of
pictures in here which i recommend to
you um those of you with the book turn
to the no it's all right um
i recommend the pictures because they
will help take you through this process
of discovery about this topic that
otherwise is i hope new to you because
it was certainly new to me now if you've
known this all along come up tell me
doing this book signing and i'll learn
from you some of the things you know
um but in the portfolio of pictures for
instance there's a photo of the black
school in pinkneyville which since 1928
has been a white house okay now i don't
know if the black residents of
pinkneyville got paid for these houses i
do know they did not get paid market
value because of course they fled in a
night of terror and it's real hard to
negotiate a fair price under that
condition okay and in many towns for
instance pierce city missouri which had
its riot a little earlier 1901 or 1902
and there's a picture here of one of the
houses in pure city had over 300 black
folks 10 of the population drove them
out in a fiery night
burned some of the houses the other
houses just got taken and got
lived in by white folks blacks didn't
get a dime for this this is just like
what happened in nazi germany in 1937-38
okay
and this happened in town after town
most recently and i think this is just
amazing most recently in 1954
in vienna illinois when the black
community was torched out
never to return
and nothing
was done about it
well i first learned of these the first
of these towns that i learned about
while i was an undergraduate uh maybe i
mentioned i went to carleton college in
southern minnesota um
carleton back then had
a bunch of people it has fewer now but
had a bunch of people from minnesota
going to it you know and many of those
were from the suburbs of minneapolis-st
paul and some of them were from the
richest single suburb and most
prestigious single suburb which was he
and still is edina and the folks from
edina said some of them with pleasure
some of them were chagrined that edina
was known far and wide for having quote
not one negro and not one jew and it
didn't either
just for the record since then it it now
does it has one of each um no it has a
bunch but
then it had none
and i thought that was outrageous
actually uh and then i learned a little
later of the notorious darien
connecticut which is one of the richest
and most prestigious suburbs of new york
city and darian was briefly famous for
this practice in 1948 the academy award
winning best picture
went to gentleman's agreement
which um
trying to remember the star
gregory peck thank you
um
which is a movie about the fact that
realtors and the power structure in
general in darien connecticut had a
gentleman's agreement to keep out jews
and of course keep out african-americans
incidentally the movie didn't do any
good locally that is to say derrian
maintained the policy for several more
decades after 1948 um but still
it became kind of locally famous that
you're supposed to be an aryan if you
live in darien
um
i thought that was outrageous and then i
learned of anna illinois um
anna is a town down by carroll 30 miles
north of cairo um and i learned that in
1909 carroll had a
spectacle lynching you know
lynchings became spectacle lynchings
around 1900 some of them did and this
was one of those by this i mean it was
announced ahead of time so it's a long
story how this lynching happened and
what the sheriff was doing and so on
it's all told in in some downtowns um
it was perhaps the first
brilliantly illuminated nighttime
lynching in the united states there's a
photo of it in the book uh a double
uh overhead um arch of bright lights
uh carol was very proud of this
illuminated carol's downtown major
intersection and this is where they had
this nighttime lynching thousands of
people came and they're all in the photo
the the illinois central ran excursion
trains to make a buck two kills come see
this famous event and a bunch of people
came from uh anna illinois 30 miles to
the north partly because the woman who
had been murdered
allegedly by the black man who was about
to be lynched
hailed from anna originally and
ironically was named anna
well after she
was killed and after he the alleged
assailant was hung in the in downtown
cairo the folks from manor went home and
thought that was such a good idea that
they drove out their black population uh
and from that day to this anna has been
known as quote ain't no [ __ ] allowed
a n n a unquote and again i i just
thought that was outrageous and so i
vowed finally to to write a book about
it and i'm actually sorry that i didn't
write it
years ago but but i've written it now
well
where are these towns
person after person has told me when i
said well i'm writing you know they said
what are you doing now you know you've
got lies my titular told them told me is
done and and lies across america and i
said well i'm working on this book on
sundown towns towns that kept out black
folks they say oh yeah down in
mississippi right alabama
no
the traditional south didn't do this
this is a phenomenon across the north
but generally not in the traditional
south now what is in
the what we might call the
non-traditional south like the ozarks if
you consider that south or appalachia
far western north carolina far east
tennessee for instance uh far west
maryland
but mississippi for instance i lived in
mississippi for seven or eight years so
i did an exhaustive search of sundown
towns in mississippi i believe i located
six okay
how many have i found in the rest of the
country
well
i grew up in illinois so i decided i
would do more research in illinois than
any other single
place
single state partly because if somebody
said
well i've heard that kenilworth is some
downtown well i knew that was a suburb
of chicago or somebody says i've heard
that villagrove had
a simon which we'll get to villagrove
siren in a minute um
i would uh
know that that was kind of in eastern
illinois
i expected to find 10
sundown towns in illinois and maybe 50
across the rest of the country
i found
472 sundown towns in illinois alone
which translates to probably 10 000
across the united states okay this is a
majority of all incorporated communities
in illinois
all right now this is
astounding and and i wouldn't blame you
if you if you don't believe me uh in
fact i want to recount a brief
conversation i had with um some folks in
wisconsin about this uh i asked these
folks one guy in particular who's a fine
scholar expert on he's a historian he
works at the wisconsin state historical
society he's the expert in the u.s on
the black press on
african-american newspapers across the
country i asked him if he knew of any
sundown towns in wisconsin and he
replied by email something like this no
you may find a few of these communities
in illinois but i've asked several of my
colleagues here at the wisconsin state
historical society and we don't believe
there are any in wisconsin
okay
well i believe that there are at least
200 in wisconsin and i have
uh found and proven at least 10 okay um
now you might say 10 out of 200 that's
not very good is it well no i didn't do
that much research in wisconsin on the
ground um i think that they that they
will prove to be so um but my
correspondent when i brought to him that
i had 10 including large cities major
towns like already mentioned manitowoc
um appleton appleton wisconsin is a city
of 50 000 to 70 000 people depending on
which census you look at and everybody
in appleton knew it to be a sundown town
as recently as the early 1970s this is
where lawrence university is this is
where a
certain man named joe mccarthy comes
from um
he was amazed
folks in wisconsin were amazed okay
so
how can i convince you that this
actually happened well i want to tell
you the moment that i really was kind of
an aha moment
when i realized that i had been
misthinking this see i've been putting
all white communities into three
categories
first your sundown towns like anna
second your sundown suburbs i need to
tell you they're a little in little
later if sundown towns are 1890 to 1940
that's when they were created sundown
suburbs are about 1905 or so to 1968. um
some of them even later but they mostly
still still being created as of of 1968
but the largest category i thought would
be all white towns that are all white by
accident that is towns that no black
folks ever went to like these little
towns around decatur i thought
why do black folks have to go to every
dumb little town that i didn't want to
live in anyway you know
okay all white by accident
so that was my residual category i still
always put a community there it's a
community of interest to me but i put it
there until proven otherwise right
then one evening
i remember it vividly it was october
2001 i was speaking at my hometown the
decatur public library
i was the keynote speaker at the second
annual decatur writers conference this
is because i'm the third best-selling
author from decatur
for the first annual one they had had
the best-selling author
for the second annual they had me the
third best-selling author i asked them
how come they didn't have the second
best-selling author who is or who was
stephen ambrose the famous historian he
was then alive and furthermore was
before his plagiarism scandal and um
and they said well that's a good
question he said because he charges
forty thousand dollars plus a private
jet both ways
and i said gee i saved you over thirty
eight thousand dollars and they said yes
yes you did uh so i was speaking at the
second annual uh
decatur writers conference and i gave my
talk about lies my teacher told me i was
going to wave it but it seems to have
moved away
and after i got done i said well now i'm
doing this research on sundown towns and
i told them what a sundown town was and
i asked them to come on down if they
knew anything about it to my amazement
20 people came down and i had my little
yellow pad
i need to say i've got my yellow paper
here and i'm going to have it at my book
signing and if any of you know about
some some downtowns that i may have
missed please tell me and i'll write
down your email and what you know and so
on we'll get we'll get some more
information because i want to out every
one of them
but anyway they all came down these 20
people and they told me that town after
town around decatur
that they understood the following about
it for instance niantic little town of
900 just northwest of decatur even
touches decatur on its northwest corner
not exactly a suburb it was an
independent town
two different people told me that they
understood that niantic had an ordinance
it said black folks could not spend the
night and that as a result of this
ordinance the wabash railroad you've
heard of the wabash cannonball it went
past my house it actually was a train
and it went through decatur uh and the
biggest yard of the wabash is in decatur
it's such a big yard it spills into
niantic and they told me that the wabash
railroad every night had to move its
work train from the niantic part of the
yard to the decatur part of the yard to
avoid offending this ordinance because
you know people sleep on the work train
and some of them are african-american
and so they had to move this train well
i confirmed later with two different old
ex-employees of the wabash that was
indeed the case
two different people told me that
um villagrove illinois which is a town
over by champaign-urbana where the
university of illinois is that
villagrove blew a whistle every night at
6 pm to tell blacks to be out of town
now i thought this was preposterous i
didn't know if you could have an urban
legend in a town of 2500 but i thought
it was an urban legend okay now was
telling me two things was it not number
one village grove has a whistle
and number two villagrove was probably
the sun downtown at least these two
people thought it was and had heard that
it was but the idea that it blew a
whistle at 6 pm i mean villagrove is not
on the way to anywhere and and you know
i'm thinking are there a whole bunch of
african-americans at the edge of town at
5 59 only to be downcast once again
because this damn whistle goes off you
know
people why not have a whistle to keep
the elephants out you know i thought it
was preposterous
so then but but you know i wrote it down
and about a year later i made a point to
visit uh villagrove and in fact i
visited villagrove uh in the late
afternoon on a saturday 4 30 p.m
i went to
the
shangri-la hotel
and i recommend the next time you find
yourself in villagrove in the evening
that you stay at the other one
the shangri-la is mostly an sro single
room occupancy for old white men and i
thought i would go interview some of
these old white men because they know
stuff you know they know them not just
about their their past and village some
of them might be from other towns and
they could tell me all kinds of stuff
you have to do this research through
oral history
stuff isn't written down
generally there are exceptions but
generally it's not written down i'll
come back to that in just a minute
[Music]
on my way up the stairs to the
shangri-la i was accosted rightly enough
by the weekend manager who was sitting
on the porch and he said can i help you
and i want to recount for you this
conversation verbatim i think i have it
memorized i certainly wrote it down
right afterwards
i said sure and i said something like uh
my name's jim lowen which just for the
record it is and i'm from decatur over
here you know i legitimized myself by
talking about where i'm from everything
and i said now is it true that
villagrove has or had until recently
because my
informants weren't sure if it if it
still sounded uh but if villagrove has
or had until recently a simon a whistle
that sounds at 6 pm and he says yes i
said well is it on a factory or a grain
elevator see i figured it was probably a
shift change at a factory um
he said oh no it's on the water tower
city property isn't it
uh so then i said um
well
why did it
uh i said does it still sound he said no
uh stopped about three years ago i had
this conversation in october of 2002 so
this would have been 1999 when it
stopped
i said well
what did it sound for why did it go off
and he said
quote
well um do you mean um originally
and i said yes originally and he said
well um originally
um
and i said to myself my god it's true
and so i said to him four words
no content i didn't want to influence
what he was going to say but i said
these four words it's okay i know
all right and he looked relieved and he
said well originally it sounded to tell
black folks to be out of town
and i was so this isn't good
interviewing i pride myself as being a
good interviewer but i was so surprised
even though i was understanding it
happening i said to him really
and he said yes and i said well why did
they stop it was it because villagrove
changed its policy and he didn't know
whether villagover changed its policy or
not but he said no they it got stopped
because people who live near the water
tower got tired of the noise okay
now to be sure for many people in
villagrove over the years it became the
six o'clock whistle right
now junior you better be home at six
o'clock for supper when you hear that
whistle go off there's no doubt that's
the main meaning of it but i asked him i
said do you mean to tell me that people
as late as 1998 99 were still learning
the original meaning of the whistle and
he said oh yes okay he proceeded to tell
me all kinds of other things about
which mayor's administration it still
sounded through when it stopped sounding
and so on i spent next monday i went
back to villagrove on monday and i spent
most of monday
interviewing other people everything he
told me proved to be true i confirmed it
with at least seven other people all
right
i'm going to close this talk with my
final interview in villagrove uh but
we'll come back i'm not ready to close
quite yet okay
um
so i became aware that this null
category this this category of uh
towns that were all white by accident
was vanishingly small that almost every
town that was all white for census after
census
was all white on purpose even if it was
in the upper peninsula of michigan even
if it was in idaho and for sure if it
was in
illinois or maryland or whatever
and not just because of that one evening
but but that was the the line of
thinking i went through
um
what else do i need to tell you
how was this maintained
well by all manner uh basically of white
male behavior bad behavior by white
folks okay i already mentioned the riots
by which these all white towns were
created uh many other towns um like
villagrove well villagrove may have
driven out its black population i don't
know but um if it didn't ever have one
then it probably and villagrove has a
strong oral tradition of having passed
an ordinance okay and in a sense it has
a visible representation of an audience
it's hard to show you an ordinance
visibly but i show this whistle uh
because it's still on the water test i
took a picture of it and put it in the
book it's a visible manifestation of the
ordinance because it was put up by the
county uh by the community excuse me to
uh
symbolize the and to
sound off the the policy
since then i found seven towns in all
that had a six pm whistle
and six of them
was for this reason including these two
in nevada that i mentioned earlier that
the whistle was to keep out native
americans
other towns are in michigan and ohio and
other places in the united states
often it was maintained in suburbs by
government policies like zoning
used in various ways i describe this
what's it called uh
exclusionary
parts of your parts of your deed
covenants thank you
racial covenants i've been collecting
them across the united states that was
used in many suburbs many suburbs in
fact required
racial covenants before allowing a
subdivision or a developer to to submit
an area for inclusion in the city
so if a if an entire city gets covered
by
exclusionary covenants then it gets on
my radar screen i'm not interested in
communities that merely keep out blacks
from bunches of neighborhoods i'm only
interested in towns that exclude blacks
or others totally
and i assert that there's at least 10
000 such communities in the united
states
i want to give you an example of other
ways it's maintained
it being this all white
nature of communities uh this is just
one typical example it's actually less
violent than most um but it's so well
written and this was written to me in an
email a couple of years ago but the
original event happened in 1978 in
arcola arcola is another small town in
illinois near also near champaign-urbana
and then in 1978 my correspondent was in
seventh grade okay
and she had learned you know everybody
knows everything in small towns she had
learned that there was a new family
moving in that had two small kids this
news excited me new babysitting
opportunities remember she's in seventh
grade okay
um later in the week i was in the school
office this is the k-12 school
when i saw a black woman at the
secretary's desk she looked angry i
overheard that her children could not
get registered for school until all
their records got transferred i also
heard overheard lots of conversation
regarding not knowing what happened to
the records and blaming the males etc it
didn't dawn on me what was happening and
didn't dawn on me either and reading
this i hope you're half faster than i am
it didn't dawn on me what was happening
until a few days later after school at
my grandfather's shop
her grandfather ran the auto body shop
in town
which was located across the side alley
from the byright grocery store that's
the main supermarket in arcola the same
woman i had seen in the office at school
pulled up to the by-right and got out of
her car with her two kids she went to
the front door and there was a closed
sign on it and the doors were locked
she looked around as i did because the
parking lot was full people inside
looked to be shopping i met her gays and
in a brief incident i had an epiphany
the light bulb was so bright i thought i
was blinded
i was so angry
i took her across the alley and she met
my grandpa
they talked in hushed tones while i
played with the kids
i overheard them talking about where she
could get some things he offered her gas
see there's an issue who's going to sell
her gas
but he had a above ground his own above
ground tank since he was a auto body
shop and he gave her the names and
locations of some amish friends of his
in the world that could supply her with
milk eggs meat etc
they were there one day and then a
couple of weeks later they were gone i
don't blame them for leaving in the
middle of the night business slowed at
my grandfather's shop for a while just
because she did that and he did that
okay
but it picked back up with the time
he picked back up with time he was the
only auto body shop in town
why haven't i heard of this before why
haven't you heard of this before
well
first of all it is the first book on the
topic
i think that's astounding i want to
compare just for a minute with lynchings
okay
uh i would assert that there are and
there have been in the history of the
united states about 10 000 lynchings how
do i get that number well the main
lynching database has in it about 4 600
lynchings but it misses a lot of them
all right so i think it misses about
half of them i mean
there's something like 10 000 in i'm
just saying something like
and there's something like 10 000 sun
downtowns okay
there have been more than 500 books
written on lynchings either on a
specific lynching or on the phenomenon
as a whole there are several hundred in
the library of congress there are
several hundred for sale right now
in huge listings like amazon.com which
will otherwise go on mentioned here um
more than 500 books on lynchings
and this is the first book on sundown
towns why is that
i think there's a reason for that and i
think the reason in part is
success
that is
we've stopped lynching have we not
now you might argue well what about that
dragging death in jasper texas for
instance well what about it
that was no lynching a lynching you know
is a public murder that's the defining
characteristic of it done with
substantial support from the community
this lynching in this murder in jasper
texas you know when those three white
folks dragged this guy behind their
pickup truck this was a private matter
done on a minor road late at night and
as soon as the community as a whole
found out about it they brought the
three people to justice they executed
two of them and gave one of them life in
prison this is not exactly with support
of the community all right jasper
stepped up to the plate did what it
should have done lynchings have
basically ended in america sure we have
all kinds of uh hate crimes including
hate murders but we do not have
lynchings in that sense it's a success
story i came to this con so we can talk
about it it's a success story i came to
this conclusion when i was writing and
thinking later about lies my teacher
told me because i note for instance that
textbooks written in america in the
1960s and 70s did a terrible job
handling the incarceration of japanese
americans during world war ii
but now they do a much better job why
because during the george h w bush
administration remember that one we
actually apologized for the
incarceration gave each survivor 20
thousand dollars in indemnity said we're
sorry in that sense it's a success story
i mean we did the right thing it took us
a long time
etc but now we can talk about it freely
some downtowns we still have many many
communities many rich white suburbs uh
and many independent towns are still
sundown as we speak okay so it's not a
success story so it's harder to face
um
what difference does it make
well i want to just suggest a couple of
differences number one
white folks growing up in sundown towns
are likely to grow up more racist maybe
this is obvious to you it certainly is
to me
uh not all of them there are some
wonderful success stories the most
famous college basketball coach probably
is john wooden for instance at ucla and
he seemed to do done fine with black
folks like kareem abdul-jabbar you know
and he grew up in a horrendous son
downtown uh martinsville indiana he got
over it all right it's possible
but
it's not so easy because one of the
things a son downtown or a sundown
suburb is telling you as you grow up
is
we're all white on purpose
and we think this is a good place to
grow up and this is good for you
well why would that be that there's only
one corollary possible right black folks
are bad for you they're an evil people
we have to be separate from them
you have to climb over that and it's not
so easy so it's bad for white folks to
grow up in some downtowns
uh i suggest it's not good for anybody
and it's bad for black folks to know
that there are some downtowns not that
we should hide the fact we should get
rid of them all right
um
it's also hard on the on the sir the
city as a system
um
around here for instance it's hard for a
community like brentwood now brentwood
maryland wasn't sundown town until about
1971. so was mount rainier so was
university park for instance it's hard
for towns like brentwood and mount
rainier to become and remain
stable and interracial now both of these
communities are about 50 50 black white
right now and increasingly latino and so
on and they are stable and individual
but it's tough why because
white folks who gain more money and more
money and more money and we all want to
do that right and more status
tend to want to move to more prestigious
suburbs it's a way of expressing your
money so they maybe want to move to
uh
chevy chase chevy chase's four different
suburbs all of which were sundown towns
all of which were created to be
specifically all white and which are
pretty much sundown towns as we speak in
the year 2000 all four communities
together had i think 17 or maybe 19
black well 19 adults in families that
had at least one black adult okay they
didn't have 19 black adults but they had
somewhere between maybe 8 and 19 black
adults in all of these communities
combined
you see what i mean it's hard because so
in illinois for instance it's hard for
oak park which is famously integrated it
was a sun downtown until about 1950 but
now it's integrated and famously
integrated but it's hard to keep
integrated because the white folks in
oak park and elsewhere in the chicago uh
metropolitan community as they get
richer they want to move to the really
best community and that's maybe
kenilworth and kettleworth was created
as a town that explicitly kept out jews
and blacks and kenilworth in the year
2000 didn't have one single black family
okay so it's not a good thing for the
social system either
so what should we do about it well i
would suggest first of all we should be
outraged all right and second of all
there's some things that the last
chapter is a bunch of remedies i think
there's things you can do individually
uh if you're black white or other and i
submit most of you in this room are one
of those three um there's things you can
do individually and and
i suggest some of them in the book um
i'll see just one here we can all work
for our state governments or the federal
government
even in its current
state of indifference to racial issues
we can
work for it to pass a residence rights
act and i describe what that is in the
book it's kind of muddled after the
voting rights act real quickly if a
community has a sundown history and this
is provable and i think i've proven it
for a bunch of them and you contribute
for others if a community has a sundown
history second if it still has sundown
geography like chevy chase does or like
kennelworth does or like anna illinois
does uh or villagrove
and it's and then it has one third
characteristic namely
there's been at least two complaints in
the last couple of years from black
folks who have tried to buy a house in
the organic house in the community and
been rebuffed or had a difficult time
then the residence rights act would kick
in and one of its provisions would be
um
houses in that community families in
that community would lose their
exemption on their income tax for
mortgage interest now of course one of
the best reasons to buy a house is
because
most of your house payments in the early
years you know are mortgage interest and
you get to take that off your income tax
you can't take rent off but you can take
off interest
well as soon as and there's a reason for
this besides the there's a legitimate
reason for this and that is the united
states and for that matter states
because they follow the same rule i want
to encourage homeownership and i think
that's good
but do we want to encourage
homeownership by whites in all white
sundown towns surely not
so let's remove that
exemption as soon as we do
every single homeowner in the community
is going to want it the community to
recruit black folks please let's
integrate you know so we can get back
our exemption this is one of the few
uh
civil rights acts that's not only free
it's actually revenue enhancing
okay
well there's other ideas about what to
do as a
remedy
i want to conclude by asserting that one
of the reasons neither you know i have
heard about this until recently
is because the the story has been
suppressed and i just want to give you
two quick examples
i mentioned to you anna
the the lead review in the washington
post this morning is about my book and
it leads off with this conversation i
had and my book leads offer the
conversation i had
in anna in 2002 i think it was
where i confirmed anna as a son downtown
the first 10 seconds i was there i
stopped at a convenience store for
coffee i asked the clerk is it true that
anna stands for
a n a ain't no [ __ ] allowed and she
says yes
that's a shame isn't it and the rest of
the conversation uh i repeat in the
beginning first page of the book
okay
everybody knows this about anna so in
1954 anna published a 450 page history
of itself called of course anna illinois
a century of progress
okay 1954 that's an interesting year for
race relations isn't it do you think
that this book is so fat and so full
that it has a paragraph or two about
every single business in town there's a
paragraph about the local dairy queen
do you think there's one word about the
expulsion of blacks in 1909 one word
about the lynching one word about the
policy one word about what a nna stands
for
nothing so you have to do this research
by oral history it's suppressed on the
whole from the written record
and even orally you can have problems
and so i want to close with this story
from villagrove i spent the next monday
in villagrove illinois talking with all
kinds of folks every one of whom
confirmed it was a son downtown and
seven of whom confirmed the story about
the whistle and its original purpose
the last interview of the day i dropped
in at the
weekly newspaper a classic office a
classic newspaper right out of 1890 that
is it's a long store front kind of like
kind of like this bookstore uh longer
and skinnier and there's a counter in
the front and then there's the editor's
desk and there's the secretary over here
and there's some more stuff in the
middle and then at the back there's the
printing press it's all right there okay
and i stepped up to the counter and i
introduced myself to the editor i said
hi i'm jim lowan i'm from over here
indicator blah blah blah and i'm writing
this book about all white towns that are
all white on purpose
such as this one
now normally i didn't do that normally i
would try to extract from him
confirmation i'd already confirmed with
11 different people that villagrove was
a son downtown so i didn't need to do
that it was 4 30 i wanted to go back to
the university of illinois where i was
spending the evening as a guest lecturer
he nodded and said yes
i said i then said quote
i understand you have or had until
recently a whistle
uh on your water tower that sounded at 6
p.m and he said yes and i said tell me
the story about that whistle
and he said quote i don't know any story
about that whistle unquote well i had
met one man previously that day who
didn't know the story about that whistle
so i thought that was possible i didn't
think it was very likely you know the
editor of the newspaper but what am i
going to do shake him and say yes you do
so i said well okay well thank you very
much and at this point the secretary
sitting right over here hyped up and she
said you mean the story that that
whistle sounded at 6 p.m to tell african
americans to be out of town and i said
yes that story and she said i never
heard that story
[Laughter]
you figure it out
that's the phenomenon of my book and the
reason i think it's so important is i
think i want you to buy it and i want
you to read it and keep it nice and i'll
just sign it blank i'll sign it to you
if you want but i just soon sign it
blank and you keep it nice and then you
give it to somebody who needs it okay
somebody who lives in one of these
communities or somebody who will do
something about it or hopefully you will
and then you pass it on to somebody else
and somebody else and somebody else
because this is a an ongoing shame in
our nation it's still going on right now
across the north we've gotta we've gotta
know about it the first way to change it
is to out it because these communities
want to be exclusive but they don't want
to be seen as excluding because that's
kind of lower class right so we need to
out them and change them thank you very
much for your attention
now i'd love to take a couple of
questions maybe even more than a couple
but you have to use the microphone so
that your question goes out to the ether
there was a study did
by hud a couple of years ago
and it concluded that freddie mae and
freddie mac
had engaged in
racial discrimination their policy for
lending
i think it was
uh 40
under the norm
for blacks something like 15 for
hispanics and 33 over the norm for
asians and then in
in 1934 the federal housing authority
that insures loans
at one time it was characterized as
instituting policy that may have been
curved from the nuremberg right to what
extent does
these lending institutions
and
this federal housing association
exacerbate
you know these kind of uh
closed communities good question um yeah
it's
it's shocking to realize that actually
having sun downtowns has been illegal
since 1917.
uh in fact in a sense it was always
illegal if you read the 14th amendment
you know
which guarantees black folks right to
make contract without regard to race for
instance and that includes the right to
make housing contracts but um
there was a supreme court decision right
in the middle of the nadir period this
terrible period there was nevertheless
one positive supreme court decision
about race i think the only one and it's
called buchanan v worley and it came out
in 1917 and what it said it was against
these ordinances called uh residential
segregation ordinances which had been
passed it was the thing to do and they
were passed by
major southern cities and even
non-southern cities as far north as
baltimore and louisville and st louis
new orleans and so on and what these
ordinances said was okay if we have a
white bloc or a majority white bloc
nobody black can buy a house on that
block we won't move out the black folks
that already happen to be living on it
if it's a majority white bloc but nobody
knew
who's black can buy a house on that
block and same thing if we have a black
bloc nobody white can buy a house on
that block okay so it's even-handed
right like plessy versus ferguson well
of course it was only enforced against
blacks who wanted to move into white
blocks um it would immediately or fairly
soon turn every city into complete
apartheid if you think about it because
fairly soon almost every house gets sold
you know somehow they stay in the family
for generations but most houses people
move people die and so on they get sold
um
why was this decision made in 1917 well
it turns out the supreme court found
that a white right was being violated i
don't think it would have done anything
of a black right a mere black light had
been violated in 1917 in the middle of
the nader but a white right was violated
how so well let's suppose you own a
house that's worth a hundred thousand
dollars of course back then it would be
a lot less but let's say in today's mark
well in today's market in dc it'd be six
hundred thousand but anyway let's say
you own a house that's a hundred
thousand dollars okay in the white
neighborhood okay and you want to sell
it and you get an offer of a hundred
thousand dollars from a white person
naturally but some black person who
wants to escape the ghetto or who wants
to live on this block or for whatever
reason wants to buy this house and is
willing to pay you a hundred and ten
thousand dollars but you can't sell to
him or her because of this ordinance so
you've lost ten thousand dollars right
haven't you not haven't you
and so see a white right the right of
disposing of your property as best you
see fit that's a white right you've lost
it so the supreme court said that's
illegal all right well if you just
follow that reasoning there's no doubt
that sundown ordinances which town after
town was passing in the north uh and
their one-sided they didn't have any two
sides about them would have been found
illegal but they were never enforced
this decision was never enforced and
even worse the federal government
completely ignored this decision by the
united states supreme court so we find
that during the
fdr administration
seven at least different towns were
invented by the federal government
including greenbelt maryland not far
from here and all of them were invented
as some downtowns blacks were not
allowed after dark there's three
different greens there's a greenbelt
type town outside cincinnati and another
one outside milwaukee
there's boulder nevada which was
invented for people who built
hoover dam
black folks helped build hoover dam but
they had to commute
the boulder was a sun downtown
richland i think it's richland uh
washington the town that built the one
of the two atom bombs
that was the sun downtown invented by
the federal government and then the fha
chimes in during the depression and
until 1968 really and the fha made a
policy of never loaning to an
interracial neighborhood or an
interracial community uh and in fact in
the book there's actually a photo of
this it's hard to make policies visible
but in detroit in northwest detroit you
can see this on the ground there's an
amazing wall in the pictures in the book
that was put up
in maybe 1950 or so a developer in
northwest detroit wanted to get fha uh
guarantees for the home loan so that he
could sell make and sell houses but it
was an interracial neighborhood but all
the black folks in this interracial
neighborhood lived toward the east the
eastern part was interracial the western
part of the neighborhood it was really
one neighborhood was all white fha
wouldn't touch it so he put up this wall
that goes from eight mile the famous
northern boundary of detroit you've
maybe seen the movie eight mile which
has some actual accurate race relations
in it it's a fine work of sociology um
this wall goes from eight mile down to a
big park it doesn't go across the
streets but it goes block to block to
block it's about this high made out of
concrete blocks faced with concrete it
still stands
neighborhood kids have put graffiti on
it and made little murals on it black
folks now live on both sides of it but
see this segregated the neighborhood so
that the the western half of it was all
white now the fha would loan to the
western half so yeah the fha was a big
part of the problem the federal
government was a big part of the problem
a huge part of the problem and it makes
a huge difference because suburbia
suburb 80 at least of all suburbs in
america were built as sundown towns with
the support of the federal government
and that was largely after world war ii
and one of the differences it makes
right now some of you may be read about
the wealth gap you know black folks make
about 70 as much income as white folks
maybe even a higher percentage of that
if you do a couple of qualifications for
education and marital status but there's
a huge wealth gap it's about 1 to 11
that is the amount of wealth that the
typical black family has is 1 11 as much
as the amount of wealth that a typical
white family has where is the bulk of
any family's wealth their home equity
okay over the generations when did it
especially happen
after world war ii when we and i speak
racially here we got support for
building or and buying our home in
suburbia levittown all of the lever
towns were
sundown towns
most most of the development by the
levite company which built eight percent
of suburbia all by itself most of that
development kept out jews as well even
though levitt was jewish
better business uh all of these
communities then
you you got a house for maybe ten
thousand dollars that is now worth two
hundred thousand dollars and that's
where much of our equity our equity and
i again speak racially comes from okay
and blacks were just flatly shut out of
that
so it's a problem to the present
no more questions come on you people
here's one
this is less of a question as saying
when people
wonder well what can we do about it it's
my understanding that the urban league
has
a couple of decades after i had moved
into
shepherd park across on the other side
of the park which itself is a racial
barrier
rock creek
the
they take you know a couple
who other than being african-american
versus white
uh have the exact same uh credentials
and everything and it's you know and
then they'll go out yeah it's called
testing yeah and um
they're still do i think they're still
doing it and if anybody wants to help
across the nation not just here in the
washington area
talking to somebody in the urban league
and getting the more local getting local
chapters
to um
do some of this stuff
might get a fire set um not literally um
you know
to to do away with it
good point thanks for that point
okay we're just going to take two more
questions the two that are standing up
already yes sir
hi i'm a teacher in the area and read uh
most of your books already enjoy them i
wanted to know
what advice you could give me as a
teacher in terms of having students
do the critical research that is
necessary so that they don't
buy at face value some of the things and
things in question in textbooks and in
in other things that they're being
taught whether it be math history
english i think they need to
be taught the skill to question and i
want to know
how they should further uh develop their
own skills as a researcher so i should
do it for them let me give you just two
ideas the first one will be in general
and the second one will be about sundown
towns uh the idea in general uh
especially in um
history or social studies
have
more than one textbook in the room so
that the idea can't be to learn the
right answer
that's in the textbook because of course
textbooks don't teach the right answer
some of them in fact teach
systematically the wrong answer as i
found out in lies my teacher told me but
as soon as you have different books in
the room a phenomenon occurs there's a
teacher right in in washington dc who
does this she has a
plastic rectangular bushel basket full
of old textbooks in the corner of her
room she teaches 11th grade
u.s history and
these are old textbook shares and from
1924 to the present and they're cheap i
mean it's not an expensive thing to do
many
used bookstores won't even handle them
because nobody wants old textbooks when
you find one that does sell them they're
50 cents so it's no great investment
she's got about 30 of them over there in
the in the box and
when things go get slow she says she
says to the students or sometimes she
does it on purpose she does it for
president hoover for instance okay
everybody go get a book and so they all
go and they know this means go get a
book from the from the bushel basket
over there so they all get their book
some of them get the same book every
time others just get whatever book they
get and they learn about hoover
and dawn if they don't learn that one of
them learns maybe the president hoover
was
very concerned about people's rights he
cared about the depression he had been
in charge of relief in europe after
world war one after all he had been in
charge of relief in
mississippi and louisiana after the
devastating 1927 flood um kind of the
precursor of our katrina disaster uh so
he cared about poor people he didn't
know what to do about the depression but
he but another person from their
textbook learns that president hoover
was a millionaire a self-made
millionaire he thought anybody could
become wealthy in america if they just
uh were
good enough and that poor people didn't
try hard enough and another person
learns
that he did care but he was hamstrung by
his republican small government ideology
was another person and you suddenly
realize it makes no sense to learn what
the textbook says because her textbook
says something different from his
textbooks or something different from
that one so then you have to think you
know that's one idea and the other idea
about sundown towns students even middle
school students and certainly high
school students can do research on the
racial history of their community
especially if it was the sun downtown
and some of them have across the country
having gotten the idea for me from my
speaking and now hopefully they'll get
it from the book
they can go interview old folks for
instance middle school students are
really good at this they can go to the
nursing home get their tape recorder on
have wonderful conversations with 80
year olds who often know a lot better
about the 1930s than they do about what
happened last week as a matter of fact i
know more about the 1930s increasingly
than i do what happened last week
and so they can they can help out these
communities by doing good research on
them and really improving and
some towns are no longer sun downtowns
and that's a great story too we need to
learn how did that happen how did oak
park desegregate how did valparaiso
indiana which was famous for being all
white community with valparaiso
university and so on and in that case
actually two black families from chicago
were recruited in and brought in and the
white professors and students from the
university who brought them in had to
maintain a 24-hour guard on the house
because people threatened them and so
but it worked and valparaiso is now over
it you know these are wonderful stories
worth telling and students can be
involved in the telling
okay
last question
it better be good
are you ready i'm ready
well it's obvious that race relations in
this country is still unfinished
business your book makes the case quite
well hurricane katrina showed that to us
so my question to you is um
given what you were saying about black
families being driven out of town and
not knowing if they were compensated for
their homes
and also the the knowing disparity
between the the family's wealth and
uh this racial policy about housing
um did the issue of reparations come up
for you while you were doing your
research definitely um
i think that the idea of reparations for
our sundown town policies and for the
entire policies we did during the nader
let's say from 1890 to 1968 because
that's when the federal government
switched sides
and there's some communities that have
yet to switch sides
i think the the idea of reparations is
definitely involved uh and we've
actually paid it once and that is for
the sundown town of rosewood florida now
rosewood rather famously drove out its
black population in 1922 i'm a
sociologist we just try to get it
approximate you know i'm within two
years i think um
and the state of florida about four or
five years ago paid reparations for that
now any such expulsion like the
explosion from vienna illinois in 1954
is a breakdown of law and order it's a
breakdown of the government among other
things because the government
is required one of its primary purposes
to make us secure in our own homes you
know to make us in a secure peaceful
community and usually of course we find
in such a situation that the government
is overtly on the opposite side but at
the very least it fails to provide
security in the home security so the
government is part of the liability
network as well as the specific white
people who did the the driving out and
that's what florida stepped up to the
plate and dealt with now tulsa
failed to deal with it about a year or
two ago and may yet deal with it uh we
hope it will um there's a movement in
tulsa to pay reparations and in oklahoma
but so far it has not passed the
legislature uh it should um
there has been no
movement in any of the other sundown
towns that i know of i have to say this
this last summer
an african-american who is the
descendant of a family in pierce city
missouri
found out about how his
family and how the entire black
community was expelled from pierce city
and this past summer got his
great-grandfather's remains exhumed from
the pierce city cemetery and reburied in
springfield missouri where because of
course there's nobody to keep up the
grave or visit the grave or anything
else in pierce city the families
cemetery plot is in springfield having
left there
over a century ago
and he got pierce city to officially
apologize for the expulsion
but i don't even know of any other i
don't think i know i might know of one
other but it doesn't come to mind right
now of the of the thousands of sundown
towns i don't think any of them have
even apologized i think at the very
least we should expect some downtowns to
do three things state they did it admit
it
we did this that's the problem already
to get them to do that number two
apologize we did it and it was wrong
and number three admit and not only
admit but state openly we don't do it
anymore we welcome everybody
after all george wallace did those three
things before he died can't we get chevy
chase to do that can't we get university
park etc to do that i think i think we
should and then the question of
reparations is perfectly reasonable uh
especially i think about like vienna
illinois there's plenty of people alive
today i mean at least several this
having happened in 1954 who were
personally driven out of vienna you know
what about them okay i think you've got
a good point there
well come up and ask me more stuff i'll
be up here signing books oh
i will show you my map if you wish this
is my beaten up road atlas
i will show you the entire county in
maryland for instance there was a
sundown there may still be a sundown
county but certainly it was a sundown
county until at least 1980. i'll show
you my map of oh i don't know what state
you want to see let's say illinois
um
everything pink
is a sun downtown probably okay plus
there's another map for the chicago
suburbs uh whatever whatever you want to
see come on up thanks a lot
down the treading operations a lot of
the machinery went uh
to the south
and we're back live in richmond virginia
for the continuation of the symposium on
civil war monuments
and historian
a historian and lawyer
an english professor in clergyman
an archivist and historian
and a sociologist i think this probably
counts for multiple perspectives
dr lowen has published and spoken widely
challenging americans to question the
sources by which we remember our past
he's best known for his provocatively
titled book
lies my teacher told me everything your
high school history textbook got wrong
and
lies across america what our historic
sites got wrong
students of the civil war know him
also for his co-edited collection of
primary source documents the confederate
and neo-confederate reader
dr lowen's first book the mississippi
chinese between white and black
in 1971
he was derived from his harvard doctoral
dissertation
his prize winning 1974 textbook
mississippi conflict and change
was the subject of a 1980 important
court decision articulating
the right to read
dr lohan taught race relations for 20
years at the university of vermont
taught previously at tougaloo college in
mississippi
has most recently been a visiting
professor of sociology at catholic
university in washington d.c
the topic is programmed today is every
monument tells a tale of three eras
implications for richmond
ladies and gentlemen dr jim lohan
[Applause]
thank you i'm delighted to be here i've
been learning stuff all day and um
it's my turn
well
i want to say that uh
recently i've been involved with
three of these controversies just so you
know a little bit more about me
i wrote a piece in the washington post
you may have heard of that newspaper um
called they have a five myths series and
it was called five myths about why the
south seceded that came out
exactly 150 years
after secession saw in 2011
and that led to
people in rockville maryland questioning
the montgomery county confederate
monument that stands next to the
courthouse there and so i got kind of
involved in the commission that they
wound up they didn't call it a blue
ribbon commission and
we didn't deserve that color ribbon
either
but anyway
and then i got involved in baltimore's
um ongoing uh well both of these are
ongoing um discussions about their
they really have seven confederate
monuments but four were on the agenda uh
of that commission and i've been
involved somewhat with the issue of
calhoun college at yale university uh
that that issue has finally been
resolved
baltimore has kind of been resolved
montgomery county has kind of been
resolved you can ask me about that in
the in the discussion if you wish
i'm going to start with a quotation
because
after all
the previous speaker wherever he is
urban uh ended with a quotation from
this guy abraham lincoln and you can't
beat that my quotation is merely from a
historian named stuart towns a recent
book called enduring legacy
and he writes
20th century white southerners learned
much of how they were going to think
about race
about the north
about the civil war and reconstruction
and about themselves from the rhetoric
of the lost cause
now surely he's right
in fact i think he understates it
and i'm going to make a generalization i
think
public history or monuments
became after 1890 the continuation of
war by other means
okay there's some other say somebody
says something like never mind you know
who who i'm alluding to
um
so
that's my name and if you want to email
me because you're upset with me or you
have something to teach me or you're
happy with me
that's my email address okay and the
book i wrote that's most relevant here
we already mentioned of course and
that's lies across america
i was going to
subject you to
a quiz that i have given to by now
probably 10 000 people
across the united states since about uh
2010
and that is the question
why did the south secede
but the waters of course got muddied by
christie this morning and and by irving
we've let the cat out of the bag already
i'm going to show you the so i'm not
going to have you vote all right
it would break my heart if you voted
wrong and
and you know there is actually a wrong
on this all right
not everything is a matter of competing
perspectives there's what we have uh
sociologists and historians agree on
calling these things evidence data all
right um there are four if i asked an
audience and as i say i've asked this on
countless college campuses i've asked it
huge school district uh teachers
600 teachers at the time in memphis and
in uh
[Music]
kind of cleveland cuyahoga county and in
south florida and different places where
i've spoken over the last six seven
years
and you always get the following four
alternatives the south seceded for
slavery
for states rights
because of the election of lincoln
and because of tariffs and taxes or
issues about tariffs and taxes
and then we vote and
christie mentioned this morning the pew
uh survey on this
my results confirm pew go back a little
further and are even worse in fact
that's the results we get nationwide
okay
and many of those people are
teachers k-12 teachers now what's so bad
about that well what's so bad about it
is the south
flatly did not secede for states rights
this is just not a matter open for
debate
i think most of you know that so i won't
beat that dead horse i will quote
two short things here from the
confederate and neo-confederate reader
um
but every document in here about
secession there are six chapters in here
but every document in here about
secession says exactly the same thing or
almost
all of them say the same uh this is from
of course the very first state to secede
uh south carolina which on christmas eve
of december 2000 december 24th 1860 it
seceded by uh convention of course and
the convention on christmas eve said
well it says a number of things it gives
a bizarre
true page or three-page history
constitutional history of the united
states that leaves out the constitution
this is not easy you might
see how it is done by referring to that
but um then they get to why we are
succeeding and here's a quote we assert
that 14 of the states have deliberately
refused for years past to fulfill their
constitutional obligations and we refer
to their own statutes for the proof now
constitutional obligations of course is
pretty vague but they go right on to
tell us what they mean they write
the constitution of the united states in
its fourth article provides as follows
quote
no person held a service or labor in one
state under the laws thereof escaping
into another shall the consequence of
any law of regulation therein be
discharged from such service or labor
but shall be delivered up on claim of
the party to whom such service or labor
may be due that is of course and you all
know this the fugitive slave clause in
the constitution and then they go on to
denounce the states rights being
asserted by various northern states they
list 17 of them the states of maine new
hampshire vermont blah blah blah they
end up with wisconsin and iowa have
enacted laws which either nullify the
acts of congress or render useless any
attempt to execute them in many of these
states the fugitive is discharged from
the sort so it's back to the s word
slavery again and they definitely have a
position about states rights they are of
course against it and utterly clear
about it they're against some other
states rights they're upset with new
york for instance because new york has
uh has come out against what we might
call temporary slavery
i used to work let's say you were
a
rich plantation couple from charleston
you don't want to spend august in
charleston
i did that once and i understand that
view
so you'd like to see some broadway plays
but you don't want to cook your own
meals up there in manhattan so you want
to bring your cook along and new york is
now saying uh-uh we're trying to run a
free state here if you bring your
enslaved cook into
new york she goes free and they're
outraged about this and they say so
they're outraged that new hampshire
along with four other northern states
lets african americans vote now who
votes in america is the state's right of
course until the passage of the 15th
amendment during reconstruction that's
two whole eras after what we're talking
about right we're talking about 1860. um
so who votes in north carolina in north
carolina too for that matter uh which
briefly for a while that blacksville but
who votes in new hampshire is none of
south carolina's business but they make
it their business and they cite against
new hampshire the
infamous jed scott
which decision did they cite
there was an incredible clip of my
tongue
some other decision from 1857 i don't
hear you all saying
yeah it was the dred scott decision i
was just teasing you
they cite the dead scot decision and
they say um
and you're letting them vote these these
people have no rights that white folks
which has nothing to do with who votes
in new hampshire of course well anyway
so they are succeeding so this 65
percent average
is dead wrong
slavery is of course the right answer
uh nothing wrong with saying lincoln the
election of lincoln that's a
trigger it's not an underlying cause but
they certainly mention lincoln fact they
call him a black republican i actually
checked lincoln was a white republican
they
of course against him and they say why
they're against him because he is the
spearhead of this new sectionalist party
that is against again the s-word so it
all comes back and nothing about tariffs
and taxes we were of course operating
under a extremely low tariff that was
written by a plantation owner from
virginia uh at the time so that was not
an issue had been an issue in 1830 this
was 1860
it's something to think about though how
come
most people including most teachers of k
through 12 are teaching it wrong as we
speak not quite as we speak the numbers
have slightly gotten in fact gotten
somewhat better in the last year and a
half just the last year and a half or
two years since i've been giving this
now it's about maybe 45 saying slavery
and maybe 40 saying states rights that's
considerable improvement you know it's
still terrible that 40 percent are
saying states rights and another 10
percent sometimes as high as 20 are
saying tariffs and taxes but it's still
an improvement
well so
one of the reasons that they're saying
this is because our public history says
it and of course by public history i
mean our monuments and historical
markers and museums and things like that
and i think that's part of the reason
why we're here
so
the
statement by historian towns is too
weak he said
20th century white southerners
learned much and we should say
mislearned much
but he could have said 20th century
americans
because i got these results in for
example north dakota
in for example an overwhelmingly black
teaching staff of memphis
so it's not just you don't have to be
white to be stupid about the past i mean
it helps
[Laughter]
in fact i have to at this point give you
two
two examples about the public i i
shouldn't take for granted that and i
kind of didn't that that you knew better
than the states rights thing but i i
hope you knew better and that's why i
didn't really rebut it oh i was i said i
was going to read you two things let me
read you just a sentence or two from
a virginia source kind of a virginia
source
this you know that after the first
seven states seceded there was a gap
and during that time they the first
seven to secede sent ambassadors to all
the rest of the slave states not sure
they did the delaware but i think they
did and they certainly sent ambassadors
to this state trying to get them to
secede
and the ambassador to virginia
uh none other than
what's his name
i got it right here uh benning he gets a
fort named for him
essentially henry benning
he painted he appeared before your
legislature the virginia legislature and
painted a lurid amazing uh picture of
what will happen if you don't secede and
what will happen if you don't succeed is
the
eventually black folks will take over
the deep south
and i'll just give you one or two
sentences from this
the white race having been exterminated
that's if you don't succeed you virginia
uh the land will go into the exclusive
possession of the black and will in
consequence rapidly pass into the con
the condition of saint domingo or haiti
uh and willing and become a howling
wilderness
the north looking on will say to itself
well blah blah blah i won't read it all
but anyway it's quite a document and
he's making this pitch to get you to
secede and he eventually did of course
uh sumter occurred to um and uh and the
rest is history
well
a couple of of uh
jokes shall we say these are
unfortunately real comments um i collect
them from the national park service
whenever i go to a national park service
site i ask what's the stupidest question
you get asked over and over
okay
and they love me to ask that question
they always have stuff and all across
from gettysburg all the way down to
louisiana at civil war sites
the one that they tell me is isn't it
amazing many many tourists say isn't it
amazing how they fought all these civil
war battles in parks
all right calm down
you can't
you can't yeah you you can all use that
use it free um
you can't make this stuff up indeed i
told that to uh my tour guide when i
toured the forum in rome and she said
there yeah we got the same question from
americans isn't it amazing how they have
all these ruins next to metro stations
but the but the follow-up comes from
gettysburg
i'm going to have to gender this i'm
sorry for half of you a a woman tourist
says how could they fight a battle hill
with all these statues
so you can never it is impossible to
underestimate the stupidity of the
american people especially when it comes
to
history
well
how could this happen this being
65 saying that we have to look at when
it started to happen this is called
historiography in history we have an aim
for in sociology it's called the
sociology of knowledge um epistemology
maybe you have to look for when it
started to happen and it started to
happen mainly between 1890 and 1940 and
we have a name for that period and the
name for that period is the nader there
it is it's not ralph it's ir
um
some people say nadir that's fine the
nader of race relations nader of course
is an english language word meaning low
point the opposite of zenith and
christie alluded to this when she
mentioned
the jim crow era jim crow is part of it
but it's much more than that okay
it's the period where native americans
and african-americans go to their lowest
point in some ways now i'm not here
telling you well it was better to be
african-american in 1855 and be enslaved
than it was in 1915 and be in the nader
i am certainly not saying that not for a
moment but i am saying uh that things
got worse and worse after 1890 and they
didn't really begin to not get worse
until about 1940. i also am here to say
that the united states meaning the rest
of us other than black folks and native
americans got more and more racist
during this era more racist than at any
other time
in our past and we see this in various
ways i'm going to let you read the rest
of it except to say that during this
period then around 1890 the south won
that by south i mean the confederate
white south i don't mean black folks i
don't mean
anti-confederates of whom richmond had
quite a few and
many other southern states did too the
and i shouldn't really say confederate
because most of them are dying off by
now so i'm going to say the
neoconfederates
won the civil war now i'm very aware
that it ended in 1865 but they won it in
1890 and they won it in several ways one
was as someone else already mentioned
they got to rename it and between 1890
and 1940 it became the war between the
states nobody not one person called it
that while it was going on while it was
going on it was either the civil war duh
or the war of the rebellion or the great
rebellion hence rebel okay so that's
completely anachronistic another way
they won it was they got to re-assert
make up what it was about and this is
when they said they the neoconfederates
that it was about states rights and as
you already saw and as this just says in
document after document it was not about
states rights in fact it was against
states rights certainly was not for
state trade
they also wanted because in 1890 they
got to
assert or i should say reassert white
supremacy
and three things happened at the end of
1890 that caused us to date the nadir to
exactly that era
and that is first of all what used to be
called the battle at wounded knee but is
now more accurately being called the
massacre at wounded knee in south dakota
where native people go to their nader
for sure
and they lose the last shards of their
independence
second the state of mississippi passes
its new constitution there was nothing
wrong with its 1868 constitution
except that it let blacks be citizens
okay and they were explicit they were
going to remove that error in 1890 and
they did uh we won't go into exactly how
you you probably know when you can ask
me but i gotta rush along and the third
thing that happened again toward the end
of 1890 well let me say this about the
second thing
the 1890 constitution was in complete
defiance of both the 14th and the 15th
amendments to the constitution but the
united states did nothing about it
um seeing this every other southern
state in states as far away as oklahoma
followed suit by 1907.
and third
toward the end of 1890
the
senate refused to pass more or less by
one vote
the voting rights act of 1890 called the
federal elections act that had been
passed by the house it would have been
signed into office by republican
president benjamin harrison
but it failed
after it failed and i'm going to have to
use the n-word hopefully just once but
i shall in a minute
after it failed the democrats did what
they usually did when they had defeated
a civil rights act and by the way the
democrats maintain perfect party unity
throughout the 19th century even if he
was elected from the state of maine
every democrat in congress voted against
every civil rights measure ever
suggested okay
you can't imagine that kind of unanimity
among the democrats today can you um
so
after they succeeded in defeating it
they did what they usually did they
tried to tar the republican party they
said you people aren't nothing but a
bunch of yes [ __ ] lovers and the
republicans in the past had said you're
darn right somebody has to stand up for
black folks in the south and for that
matter for white republicans and that
it's an outrage the violence you visit
upon them every november election but in
1891 they made a new reply and their new
reply was no we aren't
you remember the charge
no we aren't
so at that point african-americans
become without political allies and
within a few years they get dispossessed
from citizenship in virginia in every
other state
that's seated and some that didn't
well so during this era after 1890
northerners just didn't have the
guts shall we say or the
energy to dispute
the southern claim that they had seceded
for
states rights
well let's just let it go let them tell
the story
because we don't have clean hands i mean
they wouldn't say to themselves that but
that's that's how it went
so i my title as you mentioned is every
every historic i don't know if it's my
title
is every historic site is a tale of at
least two errors maybe three
it's a tale of what it's about
it's a tale of when it went up
and it's a tale of today okay and i
teach this by using
for my book lies across america i
attempted to read every single state
historical marker in the united states i
was defeated by the state of texas
texas it turns out has
more than 3 000 his status i mean excuse
me more than 13 000 state historical
markers almost as many as the rest of
the country put together and i i pointed
this out to the woman in trojan markers
in austin and her reply was well yes
we've had more history what do you
expect um
by the way virginia comes in second and
i think you actually have had more
history than than texas but that's
another matter
of all of them this is the most
fallacious this is a
piece of slate carved into the shape of
the state of idaho which is no easy task
this is not colorado is it um
and if you read it
here's what it says okay dedicated to
the memory of those who lost their lives
in a most horrible indian massacre 1861
300 immigrants westbound only five
escaped erected by
sons and daughters of idaho pioneers
1938. now why do i use this slide to
illustrate my point because it turns out
in 1861
300 immigrants in their little wagon
train were not killed in southern idaho
30 were not three were not it never
happened at all
okay and i only it's not easy to prove a
negative i only can say that with such
confidence because a fine western
historian who died recently spent 10
years of his life proving that this did
not and could not possibly have happened
and he nailed it okay
so
uh i submit that this has nothing to
teach us whatsoever about 1861 because
nothing much happened in southern idaho
in 1861. what does it teach us about
1938 well it teaches us and this is part
of the nader it teaches us that a bunch
of white folks in idaho would believe
any damn thing about savage indians with
no justification whatsoever that's
exactly part of the nader it needs to be
in the idaho state historical museum
with a sign saying artifact of 1938 and
then tells us some things about what
this teaches about 1938 almost no museum
anywhere in this country mentions
anything about the nader or even about
the little fragment of it called jim
crow right it's almost invisible
the idaho state historical society
doesn't want to take it i suggested it
to them they do want almo to take it
down but almo won't take it down because
it's the biggest thing that ever
happened in almo even though it never
happened
you can see they got they got it
decorated for christmas
it's a great country all right
i have a whole bunch of slides about the
nader this isn't a lecture about the
nature so i'm only showing you one
read it
well i don't know if you can read the
bottom
it says get out uncle
okay and by the way i've taught with
these pictures to kids as young as fifth
grade and they can handle them fine all
right they have to be taught that this
man is not the boy's uncle what do you
see maybe a five-year-old white boy
whipping this older black man right
uh get up uncle and of course uncle was
a term of quasi-respect that we used
during the nader for older and more
senior uh black americans males if they
were female aunt or auntie we still have
these terms today right aunt jemima
pancakes or uncle ben's rice
okay and the reason that this is my
favorite picture of the nader if you can
imagine having a favorite picture of
this terrible era
is because
the cream of wheat people in 1914 as it
says right behind that table
um
believe that this would make most
americans feel warm and friendly inside
and make them want to go buy their
product and i'm sure they knew their
market
another thing that happened during
the nader was lynchings went to their
all-time high and usually i subject you
to a picture of that now
several other things happened during the
nato's sundown towns one of my books
which is not for sale here but
thankfully the others are and by the way
they're at a slight discount i'm really
happy to see that
because i don't want you to pay full
price um and i will sign any book i
wrote that's my policy um
some downtowns which are you know what
some downtowns are some downtown towns
that are all white on purpose they are
massively common across the north even
to this day many are still sundown
they are
very uncommon
in the south you did have colonial
whites excuse me colonial heights
that is the nickname you know uh and you
do have two and a half maybe three whole
counties way west in virginia that were
sundown counties uh they're common in
appalachia therefore and they go down
into the northern part of alabama um
they're in the ozarks but they are
otherwise not common in the south this
is a northern way to be racist um
well they happened
during this
same nader period
now this
is a confederate monument many of you
have seen it it's in alexandria it's
right in the middle of the street this
is an issue in fact this was a
recent issue in alexandria just like so
many many many towns and and counties
across the united states not just in the
south are having issues these days about
confederate names and confederate
monuments and confederate buildings and
so on
this is a monument before the nader
and earlier talk
made me aware that many northern
monuments were also pensive i would say
that's pensive wouldn't you
kind of looking hmm
maybe this wasn't the best idea anyway
this certainly was a tragedy and like
most of the early monuments it is
covered on three sites with the names of
the dead all right
uh it's a very different frame of mind
and a very different spirit than that
all right that is a nader monument okay
that is triumphant it's triumphant in a
whole bunch of ways and i don't have to
explain there's even a word for that
it's called hieratic scale that's a art
history word i guess um
so
of course
the nader didn't set in crisply on
january 1st 1890 you see some monuments
after that that is to you see some
triumphant ones before and so on but
most confederate monuments go up during
the nader between 1890 and 1940 and when
you eliminate those monuments that are
at cemeteries almost all confederate
monuments go up between 1890 and 1940
and they go up in places of power
like this one uh well monument row
monument avenue is not exactly a place
of power but it's a
impressive important avenue uh many of
them go up as you have at state capitals
at county courthouses uh like the one in
in rockville maryland and so on earlier
monuments had mostly gone up at
cemeteries so these new monuments are
saying something quite different they
are in line with the new statements
being made about the civil war we were
right
deo vintage or however you pronounce
that um we were right
and we have the power to say so and
we're saying it big
so
in the last 10 years mel
16 years
richmond has taken some heroic steps
to deal with its public confederate
public history which is confederate um
i've kept track of richmond um in my
book that i mentioned lies across
america richmond gets more entries than
any other city virginia gets more
interest than any other state
before you say geez we must be great
remember it is called lies across
america
but
i'm
allegedly slowly working on a book a
third book about how we remember the
past to be called surprises on the land
unexpected places to get history right
and you're going to have a bunch of
sites there too and i was talking about
this both yesterday and today with some
folks from richmond who don't even know
some of the things that you've got so
let me just mention really quickly a few
of them i keep track of richmond i come
down here often and it's amazing how how
the city has changed and mostly for the
better um
you
now recognize lincoln's walk
you know what i'm talking about
some of you do
see the ones who nodded ask them
[Laughter]
you of course have this new lincoln
statue about which christie spoke
i know how that came to be and it's kind
of a capitalist invention but still it's
very
it's accurate and it's very interesting
uh you have the slave walk
you have all kinds of stuff done by this
group hope in the cities it has another
name too
you have this guy ralph white i don't
know if you know these people but he was
working for the park
department and put up surreptitiously he
put up all these um
markers about
accurate history along the riverside and
now many of them have become
what's the opposite of surreptitiously
fictitiously
many of them have become more official
now okay
you have
this one i was talking with people
yesterday and they didn't know about it
reconciliation which is about the
triangle trade there's very little
anywhere in the world in very few places
in america that talk about the slave
trade because the slave trade is even
less
palatable than slaver e all right and
yet you have this and of course it ties
in with two other monuments one in
africa and one in the united kingdom of
course you have this
uh
wherever it is you have arthur ashe
you know about that you have a new
completely new interpretation in may
mount mansion uh
you have this this is lumpkin slave jail
before it got recovered back up uh this
is a whole story that i don't have time
to get into but you guys uncovered it
and did a good job with it then put more
dirt on it because you didn't have time
to do something with it and uh so it's
kind of an incomplete story you of
course have the amazing civil rights or
school desegregation monument at the
city capitol
and various other things so
now i'm impressed
at the same time
let's see what my next thing says
i thought i said yeah let's read that
despite heroic steps towards change
which i've just delineated
richmond's public history
has only gone
a little bit of the way of where you
need to go and i submit if we can
divorce ourselves from this time if we
can put ourselves 10 years hence or 40
years hence um maybe you keep mentioning
uh when when the social definition of
race is less important to us
uh hopefully uh we will see how little
of the distance we had come by 2017 and
how much farther we have to go and so
unlike uh irwin i'm going to tell you
what to do
however
however i recognize fully that i don't
even live in the state and i'm going to
tell you what to do and i'm going to
leave and
so you're going to do you're going to
listen to me and then hopefully and then
you're going to do what you want to do
but i i'm just going to give you some
suggestions some ideas okay and you you
make them from what you what you will
i submit that every one of your
uh
civil war monuments is a creation of the
nader period and it has
more to tell us about when it went up
than it has to tell us about what it's
about okay
and so you folks have to make clear that
these monuments tell first and foremost
about the era in which they went up
that's the story that they have to tell
us you catch what i'm saying how can you
do that well until you do that i want to
suggest to you that they will basically
connote what the confederates in this
parade know that they connote namely
these are valuable people they were
great we revere the heck out of them
that's why we built these huge statues
of them there's no way to get past that
almost how how can we get past that well
here's maybe a couple of ideas
i'll just
give them to you before we even get to
monument avenue
you've got jefferson davis highway it
starts at the potomac river do you know
that it winds its way through various
parts of virginia and finally all the
way to mississippi and then it goes off
for no known reason to los angeles and
goes up to the canadian border north of
seattle i'm not sure exactly what
jefferson davis did in northern
washington state but that's where it
goes okay it's time to unname it all
right all jefferson davis highway does
it does two things naming it for him
number one it says he was great and
number two it says and we honor him
now he was great nobody could be head of
a insurgent government and put it
together too and not be great
uh lots of people are great we don't
have to make any of the odious
comparisons that can come to your mind
but
and we honor him that second part is a
problem and why do we we don't honor him
for being a really good secretary of
state or really good secretary of war or
a really good senator from mississippi
of course not we honor him because he
led the confederacy in the revolt
against the united states on behalf of
slavery that is a problem and that is an
understatement okay so you gotta unname
it and put marker alexander's already
done that so they've handled the upper
end of it but you can handle it as it
goes to richmond
put a marker up at
both ends of it coming through richmond
explaining that it used to be the
jefferson davis highway and why it got
renamed why it was named when it was
named who named it that is part of the
nader and why we renamed it because
we're no longer racist or at least not
racist as a
primary
description of our political activity as
was true in the nader
so that would be great then it tells
history admittedly that part of history
is only told when you stop and read the
marker but it's better than what it is
now there's no
there's nothing but the name
i think you need to get lincoln's walk
onto the landscape so that you get so
people can follow it without doing it
just on special occasions but
absolutely
saying what happened every step of the
way we know that we've got really good
sources on it um reconstruct we are now
in the sesquicentennial of
reconstruction aren't we and that's a
fascinating era that is so misunderstood
still and almost invisible on the
landscape and richmond could take such a
terrific lead there's not one place in
richmond that was a slavery place that
isn't also a reconstruction place right
by definition unless they blew it up and
it vanished in 1865 which didn't happen
so ever there's there's
markers you can put at the capitol at
city hall and all kinds of other places
that's why there's blank
a good marker for william mahone
how many of you know who william mahone
was
well that's more than average but fewer
than half of you
well this marker doesn't say nothing
except about what he did in the civil
war
well it does say he was united states
senator afterward but that's all it says
he made a remarkable transition you know
he became the leader of the readjuster
party which was a black white coalition
which uh had some
sensitivity to the to the idea of black
folks being citizens and he's therefore
a person with whom white
a person whom white youngsters need to
know about and for that matter if you
think about it black youngsters need to
know about two you know that virginia
produced such persons and there's lots
of them there's the guy who came in
second in your election for mayor in
1864 i think i'm knowing within one year
um who was a peace candidate and would
have tried to take richmond
out of the civil war you know about him
he needs a good historical marker okay
well i got some
now monument avenue we have to get to
monument avenue i think i'm
just on time
monument avenue is as it is is going to
stick
in richmond's throat like a fish bone
from here on
as you did during your
amazing bicycle base okay
it will never be a unifying
place for richmond again
and there's a sense in which it never
was except the people who were not
unified by it
weren't really citizens and couldn't do
anything about it
there's plenty of white folks who don't
like monument avenue either of course so
what can you do about it well you could
move them all to a nadir park
or to a confederate cemetery that would
be interesting and i would make a it
would cost if it's seven i think you
guys need to get better bids in
charlottesville
seven hundred thousand i i can't believe
we can't get it done for 95 but anyway
um but if it costs
if it costs what that's
pretty awesome
well the legal fees could bring it up to
700 i'm getting heckled from the front
row here in a positive way so um
so if it's 700 000 for that little bitty
thing down in charlottesville this is
probably a four billion dollar
enterprise but still um put them all in
a nadir park nobody else has a nadir
park
[Laughter]
figure think of the tourist money i'm
not even kidding on that last point okay
um
or
if you can't do that or unwilling to do
that or it's too expensive
how about desegregating the row sexually
how about adding elizabeth van loo and
mary bowser you know who those two folks
are and
here's where you can put them
you can put it wherever you want them
but there's a little place on monument
avenue that's got a cross street coming
in i think it's mulberry and um she
could be right there bowser and van loo
could be right behind me the two of them
looking each other you don't have to
make another one of those circles that
cost money to make a traffic circle uh
just have them kind of
speaking toward each other across the
across the street blow people's minds
you know and explain what was going on
there
um
here's an idea for
jefferson davis can you see that a
friend of mine who's even
who's slightly better at photoshop than
i am but not very
um you've already got this
kind of bars going across there
how about
put in there
real
sculptures representing some of the
hundreds of slaves that he owned
or or you come up with your own idea
about that let's see what other ideas i
have
after all
you did do that one
and and that was hard to get done now i
know there's criticism to be made of it
but it also had some very interesting
and positive um effects
one of which was on
the udc
the united daughters of the confederacy
after this statue went up with this
monument
the united arabs of the confederacy had
on jefferson davis's birthday i think on
his birthday always put a wreath at his
at this
after this went up
even though it's not anywhere near
this
this mari is in the way and
probably a mile of the avenue uh after
this went up they took they don't do it
anymore they now put the wreath at
um
hollywood cemetery at the at the uh
tombstone of jefferson davis very
interesting so
they concluded that monument row is no
longer our
space okay and that's just from this one
statue down at the end of it if you
stick in mary bowser and elizabeth who
else
somewhere in town you need to have some
impressive recognition of the usct the
united states color troops who indeed
liberated richmond and i make that
statement absolutely deliberate there's
no doubt that a majority of the people
living in richmond wanted to be
liberated when they came in all right
and quite possibly a majority certainly
a large minority of the white population
at that point wanted to be liberated
again that brings us to the fact that
almost nowhere in richmond or in the
entire south is there any notation on
the landscape that there was a massive
and increasing peace movement during the
confederacy there was a peace movement
contingent to the bread riot and i don't
know where the blood riot's memorialized
in this city is it
it is on the on the landscape
okay good tell me about that afterwards
because i couldn't i couldn't learn um
let's see what else i want to see
i think i have one more slide to show
you i was going to try to get you to
sing this
but i'm not
this is my favorite verse
of the
civil rights anthem we shall overcome
i think it's true
that is to say i think
if you look carefully at history
you find for example no evidence
whatsoever
for black inferiority
all right
you actually find for instance that
reconstruction was not a a period of
intense corruption and disaster and
violence by the black popula you
actually find a lot of violence by the
white by some of the white population
but
i think accurate history is
in fact useful to us all as we try to
achieve
justice in the present i think that
there is a reciprocal relationship
between truth about the past
and justice in the present
reciprocal in the following way for
instance
you know from my book lies my teacher
told me i read
first 12 and now 18
high school history textbooks in u.s
history
i am the only american ever to have
attempted this feat
it was a near-death experience
it took years of psychotherapy
but
i see a change in them in how we treated
for example
japanese americans during world war ii
now this was a known fact in 1942
we knew what we were doing was in all
the newspapers
in the in the history textbooks of the
late 40s in the history textbooks of the
50s even the 60s one tiny little
paragraph about it often or if it's more
often agreeing with the policy okay okay
in the history textbooks of the 1990s
and 2000s
considerable treatment often a photo in
one case a two-page spread and they
don't let us off the hook now why is
that well because right at the cusp of
the reagan and george h.w bush
administrations and with the involvement
of both of those administrations we
apologize did we not and we paid
reparations of 20 thousand dollars to
each survivor
in that sense we made it right i mean
yes they we didn't make it right exactly
but we did what we could it therefore
becomes
an american success story
similarly if you will
we now have fairly good treatment of
slavery in several american history
textbooks because we did end it you know
i mean yes there's arguments that it
continues even today with our arrests
and i know all that argument but we did
literally end it and so it becomes an
american success story so i think
justice in the present helps us be
better able to
see truth about in the past and i think
certainly my whole work is based on the
proposition that truth about the past
can help bring about
greater justice in the present
and i think what you folks do in
richmond in that regard
could be a guide and a lamp for the
entire nation
thank you for your attention
i am allowed to take two questions one
of which has already got his hand up and
not more there's the other
we're
hand
because
we're going to have a whole discussion
group then a panel after a brief break
for cnn to reset question one
being the stupidest white person in the
room
which you said we were all
uh in some sense um i find the
explanation of secession by slavery
period
extremely simplistic
i don't find it in any other war
where were one world war ii
uh the coming world war three if we have
one
a lot of people go back to the documents
and say every state the south it was
slavery slavery slavery slavery slavery
if i go through the divorce papers of
everybody in this room i bet it's all
our 95 percent incompatibility
it's not one explanation it can't be one
explanation
and i don't think you gave enough
choices up there
please respond okay um
i when i said that slavery i i actually
said slavery was the cause of secession
okay uh not of the civil war um i do not
i did not mean to imply and i hope i did
not imply and i certainly don't imply
that the united states went to war to
end slavery the united states had no
such thought the united states went to
order to hold the country together that
was its only statement and as many of
you know who have studied the civil war
it took some time and some actions on
the ground including actions by african
americans to make ending slavery a war
aim of the united states which of course
it became formally only with the
preliminary announcement of the
emancipation proclamation in the early
fall of
1862 and that's quite a bit after the so
i'm not trying to claim that the united
states went to war with the high moral
ground of ending slavery not at all now
in terms of why southern states seceded
if you do not assert if you do not agree
that it's slavery then you have to
answer the next question which is
why did every southern leader who
proposed secession
lie about why because they all say
we are doing this about slavery now
there's a broader sense in which i agree
with you
two other possible reasons one is white
supremacy that is slavery is a tool in
support of white supremacy you get that
from that benning thing i already
wrote you
slavery is important to her and this is
why
a common neo-confederate dodge if you
will is to assert well lots and lots of
confederate soldiers didn't have any
slaves that's certainly true and
incidentally when i say that the south
went to war for slavery that doesn't
mean that individual soldiers went to
war for slavery they went to war because
their street height would really want
them to or because their best friend did
or for all kinds of reasons uh i have a
cousin who
wound up in vietnam because he wanted to
learn how to fly an airplane you know
so that's why he went to war
so i'm not talking about that um
so so maybe i've answered it
because otherwise you have to have an
assertion um why would they lie
and i've never seen anyone attempt that
explanation and i certainly haven't ever
seen a convincing one at the very least
um if the if the
leadership of
uh let's say jefferson davis or the
leadership of south carolina or
mississippi mississippi you know has the
most blatant statement of them all uh
i won't i won't find it for it's
something like uh our
cause is thoroughly identified with the
cause of slavery
blah blah blah it couldn't be clearer
now
if that's not the cause or if there's
something else that's at least equal or
majorly the cause
why wouldn't they mention it um maybe
it's because it wouldn't be convincing
to the to the general people who is the
the audience for these statements uh
when they when the conventions make a
statement about why we're succeeding
they're first of all trying to
convince south carolina or mississippi
or texas why they're succeeding and
second of all they're talking to you
they're talking to the citizens of
virginia and this is why you ought to
join us and so on now there is john a
logan who is a very interesting man uh a
general in the north and who wrote his
autobiography and it's terrible don't
ever read it um
but it's interesting and i once bought
it um and read it um
he argued that it was simply to have
their own country to be in charge and be
powerful
no doubt in a sense now you can't make
that argument nobody is ever going to
say we're succeeding so that i'm going
to be in charge you know having lost the
election or whatever or was it so of
course and by the way some people say
well they were seceding in order to have
the state's rights to secede
now you may have noticed that we're
circular and that's why they didn't make
that argument okay no they never say
that of course so i wouldn't argue
against john a logan's argument but
the only thing i see people actually
arguing is secession i mean is slavery
including the expansion of slavery into
the territories and for that matter the
eventual expansion of slavery southward
like maybe mexico and maybe cuba okay
so that would be my answer at least
never mind about that second question
we'll put it into the panel
thank you for your attention
okay there'll be plenty of time for
questions for jim and the other
panelists in just a few minutes we are
going to take a break to allow c-span
to adjust the lights for the panel
uh it's only about five minutes so if
you
please stay in or around your seats
while we're doing that i'll tell you
i really appreciate it personally that
jim talked about william mahone
i grew up about four or five miles from
that marker that he showed you and
william mahone was not a big man he was
five feet tall and weighed 95 pounds
and in uh one civil war battle he was
wounded and it was reported to his wife
that it don't worry it's only a flesh
wound and she said but billy has no
flesh
now later along with the
being the
leader of the readjuster party he was
also the person who merged all the
railroads in virginia that became the
norfolk and western
and
it was originally named the
atlantic mississippi and ohio railroad
or called the amno now his wife's name
was otilius so every time he merged a
railroad he would get the state to put
up all sorts of cheap
bond money to do it and he would take
the stock
so the joke was the
stood for all mine and otilias
so he was he was quite a character
by the way we've gotten
some good uh texts and emails
uh during the course of the symposium
from the live tv audience and um
by the time we get started
i will take the moderator's prerogative
and pose one of them from our tv
audience
to the panel
john has asked me to remind you that
after we are through we will have the
the counter still open for book sales
okay ladies and gentlemen let's convene
the
the panel
it has been a good day so far uh pleased
during the course of the
is is somebody got a video or something
going
um if you could turn that off that would
be great
um uh we'll reconvene the the panel it's
been a good day so far uh what we'll do
is
recognize you with you raise your hand
wait for the microphone
if you've got a question please re that
should be referred to one of the
panelists please designate that
and
please
try to stick to questions rather than
statements
now let me start with a
a question that we got
in virtual space
my name is mike powell and i'm president
of the brunswick civil war roundtable in
southport north carolina
we are i believe the largest roundtable
in the us
i've gone to great lengths to keep
politics out of the round table
this topic monuments has both elements
of history and politics
what do you think should be the role of
round tables
if any on this issue
we thought that was a very good question
i and i would broaden it and say uh
civil war buffs who know more than the
general public what should we do
on this issue
and
tom i'll ask you
first
well
emerson said that you can no more stay
out of politics than you can stay out of
the frost
they're they're part of the environment
you live in and i think if you think
you're keeping politics out of it you
are probably just kidding yourself
uh um had a quotation about a sentence
that said if you haven't you know if
you're
in a situation of uh
a moral situation and you you uh
claim neutrality and you've probably
chosen the side of the oppressor
i'm not sure that i'm not saying that
applies to every monument situation but
i think it's a it's a
good principle about the whole idea of
thinking you don't have politics
um so anyhow my advice would be um
try to have an environment in which you
can have political discussions and
recognize this as a political discussion
okay
no question i mean you i don't see how
you can avoid politics
and the war
but i think
my experience with roundtables is
a really gratifying
kind of
civility and i'm aware of how different
perspectives
that people bring to that kind of
circumstance
but my experience with them
has been that they
they're really interested in the history
and in some ways you have to let aside
some of the sharper edges of what you
want to say
and let and let the history speak for
itself let it speak
urban
the problem with civil war roundtables
in the south is that the vast majority
of them are pro-confederate there's just
no way around that that's why they exist
i'm not saying they're advocating
slavery but they are pro-confederate the
reason why i say this is because i was
going to suggest that the gentleman
consider having his round table help
sponsor uh free and open public debate
on the issue of monuments in their their
area but i can see a large segment of
the local population probably not
wanting to participate just because the
fact it would be sponsored by a civil
war roundtable and which they would see
as pro-confederate i'm specifically
talking about the african-american
community
i mean look at this audience i mean how
many african-americans in this audience
this has been something i've been
grabbing with for 25 30 years i mean i
go to audiences like this i'm not saying
you folks shouldn't be here and i'm not
glad to see you but i'm always a little
dismayed at the low number low turnout
of african-americans in civil war
history roundtables and discussions like
this
jim you were waving your hand like pick
me monty uh it's your turn
well
uh
i agree with what irving just said
that's that's an absolute poem and i do
see some people in some of these
discussions that i've been in
uh using their admittedly superior
knowledge of the civil war because
they're in civil war roundtables and
because they've been interested in it
and study maybe they're reenactors and
all those kinds of things and they've
been studying it for 40 years
and
using that as kind of um armor or
ammunition if you will
against a 19 year old african-american
recent graduate from high school who
explains why she is offended by
the lee jackson
double equestrian statue in baltimore
for example and that they're
talking past each other
on the other hand um the civil
since i just argued and closed my talk
of the argument that the truth shall set
you free i think the facts about the
secession and the confederacy and the
civil war and reconstruction and so on
are absolutely useful uh unfortunately
these could be heavily ideological uh
conversations in which facts don't
really make much of an appearance uh if
they if you
do
use primary sources you maybe know what
you're talking about you know um so i
and the civil war roundtables i've been
in like the one in washington dc these
folks know lots of stuff and i found
that they're they're quite useful and
[Music]
important members of the conversation
christy
i've been
like most of the folks up here
different points in time been invited to
speak to civil war roundtables of
varying sizes i do agree um with
dr jordan's perspective that when it
comes to civil war history in particular
um african-americans have because they
were deliberately taken out of the
narrative from the beginning
and have
has a national narrative where where
freedom was given
versus earned or right
they do not engage with this period of
history
for very real reasons
i grapple with it when i go out and when
i go out and i talk about
roles of african americans in the war
and things like that i get this you know
this this this awakening right
but at the same time there's still a
hesitancy
but i do think that civil war
roundtables can be a part of
so in that case i would say
if your civil war roundtable whether
you're in chicago or whether you're in
chicago or whether you mean a washington
or here in richmond or powhatan county
or wherever you happen to be
i think the key
is finding a partner where together you
can decide
how
best
to help your community look at the
history especially if you don't have a
museum or historical society that is
there to help guide those conversations
that would be my suggestion
i would just say by the way that i first
met dr jordan 22 years ago is a member
of the chicago civil war roundtable and
they would refer to me as their token
southerner
[Laughter]
one more question and we didn't
none of you delved into it very much we
talked about do you leave the statues
alone or do you move them but one of the
things that we hear quite a bit is
can you put up appropriate interpretive
signage along with the statues that
contextualize not only what is the
statue of
but as
jim particularly was talking about
when it was put up and why and what have
been its
controversies if you will over time
is is that an effective way to deal with
uh the discussions that we are having in
the country today
jim let me put that to you first and
then let's get some other media yeah
yeah
all these gyms um i think sometimes it's
the best that you are likely to get done
and i think it can be done well i think
i had i didn't read it but i think one
of my slides said uh contextualize this
the
monument
i
let me just go say this i probably
didn't write it contextualize it so
heavily yet so accurately that
neoconfederates will be the ones trying
to deface it
instead of blm people
all right but yet you heard me say yet
so accurately and in baltimore uh so far
although the commission there uh came
out with a recommendation to move two of
the four statues so far they haven't
moved any but they have put up one
um
plaque in front of each of them and let
me just read you a phrase from
from this of
plaque let's see
this is from the one about the the lee
jackson dual equestrian statue that some
people are very very proud of um
these two men became subject of the lost
cause this is after a whole paragraph
this is not the beginning of the plaque
these two men became subjects of the
lost cause movement which portrayed them
as christian soldiers and even as men
who opposed slavery today current
scholarship refutes these claims these
larger-than-life representations of lee
and jackson helped perpetuate the lost
cause ideology which advocated for white
supremacy portrayed slavery as benign
and justified secession
that's helpful
it still doesn't compete
compared to the magnificence of the
statue the hierarchic scale of the
statute the
possibility that you're really supposed
to kind of stand in awe of the statute
that's still a problem tom brown you've
seen a heck of a lot of statues have you
seen it done successfully somewhere
not that i can think of offhand but i do
think that
technology is something that could help
to make this a more feasible strategy
than it has been before as jim said
there's a mismatch between having the
the monument which is kind of the memory
um
as an instrument of memory and the the
signage um but if you had um
something that someone could listen to
on their uh on their phone that would be
accessible and and appropriately
attractive and brief um especially if it
is something that could give you the
story as you were looking then the the
kind of modern interpretation could go
with looking at the the monument instead
of competing with looking at the
monument and i think could be even more
effective than than it is right now
that's an interesting uh
question that we museum professionals
really
appreciate
i remember having someone in the museum
that was
there was an exhibit label talking about
south carolina's secession and he's i
had him read it he said but you didn't
mention this and you didn't mention this
and you didn't mention this and i said
okay good say it how you would like to
say it and use 70 words right
because if it's more than 70 words the
visitor will not read any of them so
one of the difficulties as uh
jim lowen pointed that on the state
historical sign on the william mahone
birthplace is
you're limited to the number of words
and technology may be the way to get
beyond that
so
tim i speak to that
my perspective
someone in english is that you're
looking at a very complex
literary
text
and
i don't think there's a final
word on it that's why they're there i
mean they're supposed to last forever
they should last forever they should be
there way after us
in terms of the materials that they're
made
and i think it's
i find them vexing i really find them
interesting i mean just the one word lee
on both sides the graphic you know but
it's lee you could do three volumes
i wouldn't write it but you could do
three volumes on what they're saying by
just making that simple claim you know
in in rey's letter so i i think the the
final word
is is just
unobtainable
okay uh questions from the audience
thank you i think my question would be
for dr lauren uh here first
i noticed that
many of the u.s army bases in the south
seem to be
named for
generals of the rebellion
is this something that occurred after
the nadir um or was it before that uh
yeah it occurred during the nato is i
think what you meant yeah after 1890 and
during the nato exactly and and i think
it's incredibly problematic uh if you
read not just what i read you from
benning for instance and we have for
this fort benning um
it's astounding white supremacy i mean
and of course
who knows what 30 of the folks
that are enlisted at fort benning or
probably african american
if if i were one of those 30 percent or
for that matter giving me a little
credit if i were a white person
stationed at fort benning i would have
problems with that name okay and a
couple of them
in addition were terrible generals and
they kept losing um
i don't understand why we would name a
for an enemy and be an incompetent so i
think these need to be
addressed
thank you
uh george calvin richmond um related to
the land that is under most statues be
they
uh public or private land what are the
basic real estate questions that need to
be asked whether their easements who
holds the title who may have done the
original funding and
are they potentially located on land at
state or federal landmarks
tom do you know i i think the answer is
going to be there's a lot of different
answers to that question it's a
vastly decentralized process in which
the answer those questions can be
different from many different monuments
anyone else jim yeah often they were
placed on publicly owned land um it's
not clear that the
deed
that they needed it to the for example
municipality um so for example in
rockville maryland
it's on the courthouse
grounds which is county-owned land and
the county exec this makes a difference
right now and it's a good question to
ask
the county executive has decreed that
the statue will be leaving that site
exactly where it's going and and when is
another issue
right now you all should go there
because it's kind of interesting there's
a big crate around it uh if you get up
high like you go through a nearby thing
and look down you can still there's no
top to the crate so you can still see
part of him um he's up there in that
crate because uh he got vandalized once
and this is going to stop and it also
kind of
stops the protest because
how you're going to protest a bunch of
plywood you know it's just kind of
already taking away the the import the
import of the of the statue but the city
uh claims an interest in the matter the
udc
maybe still owns it they donated it but
maybe they didn't maybe they just loaned
it kind of so there's all these
complexities for each one of these
in the case of charlottesville the lee
jackson statues in their parks were
donated by one man paul goodloe mcintyre
who
born in an area left went to chicago
made his fortune so he purchased the
land
and he paid for the statues and i think
that sometimes if if it wasn't for him
the statues wouldn't exist i don't think
charlottesville would have spent that
kind of money back in the 1920s to erect
those statues in the deed of give and
i'm probably other than myself and my
lawyer friend mr martin out there we're
probably one of the few individuals in
charlottesville that actually read the
probably rape that was the deed of gift
which says that the parks have to beat
in perpetuity however there is a clause
that says something like subject to the
administration of the city manager or
city government mr martin is that right
here so there's that so a lot of these
parks were probably done by private
individuals certainly in the case of
charlottesville
and that's part of the problem in
charlottesville right now is that some
people are arguing that well it was a
private donation it's public land now
but it was a private donation so we can
do whatever we want to the parks but
that remains to be seen
questions yes
i'm doug hellner i do volunteer work for
the national park service at arlington
house
uh one of the things we read across in
my reading is that lee went on record as
not approving any kind of construction
for any kind of confederate memorial in
fact i tell visitors he was one of the
first people to bail out on the
confederate experience
why has this point not been brought
forward
because it doesn't fit the lee mythology
that's not being flippant that doesn't
fit the lead mythology
you know any it's curious because any
anti-confederate sentiments that lee
expressed after the roar after the war
largely been buried even by his admirers
and apologists they don't talk about
these anti-confederate
statements that he made i mean he told
young men after this after the war
put your uniforms away and forget it
yeah but you don't hear people say that
even lee's defenders you don't hear them
say that very often in public right
those those fundamentals those men davis
and lee
who are colossally imperfect
we're also trapped as symbols they
symbolize
so it's
their their symbolic importance is more
important than their private views yes
as individuals they're left they're
that's not their import they're
important as import as symbolic
representatives of
the cause as it were is
what they're remembered for
it's interesting
as symbols
how about right here
hi i'm jerry swirling of richmond and um
we talk a lot about context
but it strikes me as a result as we've
already heard it's going to be very
difficult to achieve context and the
problem seems to go beyond context it
also seems to get to balance and scale
context alone might not do it so my
question for anybody is might we be able
to step back
and look at this problem in a larger
kind of context and think of those
monuments as being part of the greater
richmond slavery history
and think about
lumpkins jail
and think about the slave walk
and think about how we bring all of this
together to tell the whole story and
then establish in so doing establish a
greater context for the monuments on
monument avenue
i think that's what i was talking about
no i think that's exactly what i was
talking about that i think has saved um
richmond some of the more
volatile conversations not to say we
haven't had our impassioned
conversations here
it's because the landscape has been
changing dramatically especially in the
last 20 years
and since it's been changing and since
richmond itself is discovering things
that it never knew
i mean i you know i came to richmond in
2008
even though i grew up down road peace in
williamsburg
i came to richmond in 2008 to become a
part of this community and even in the
short nine years
there's been a remarkable change in the
way the city views itself and part of
that i will say is because of how
richmond chose to commemorate the
sesquicentennial
it was really huge to add the word civil
war and emancipation it was the only
state to do that
and with that a deliberate decision to
have conversations about the war and its
impact and totality
simultaneously you had the work that was
happening at lumpkin's jail most
richmonders and this this was what was
stunning to me is that most richmonders
didn't even recognize that richmond
burned because of confederates
right
they had no idea that the very district
the very district that burns shaco
is the heart of richmond's slave trade
it is the heart of its commerce it is
the heart of what the confederacy wanted
to destroy and keep from federal forces
and because it disappeared from the
landscape
it became
again landscape
because it disappeared from the
landscape it became much easier to put
those things away as if they weren't
important so when this community started
to rediscover because of that
archaeology work because of that public
history work because of the
conversations that were taking place the
narrative got bigger
and then because the narrative was
getting bigger and because we were there
there were
groups large and small and and richmond
is the kind of place where change takes
a long time and it's always organic is
the other thing these are not government
push things this is an organic on the
ground movement of people saying if our
community is going to be healthy if our
communities are going to be just if we
are going to tackle the injustices of
racism and poverty and economic
disparity and all these things we have
to change the narrative
we have to get the narrative right
and so our landscape is beginning
to do that
i have to say the one thing that there
was only one thing
but
one thing that struck me is just like of
course that makes perfectly good sense
this idea of putting women on monument
avenue i absolutely love that
let's put civil war women or women let's
put them over there
um because we have remarkable women in
in richmond's history that are game
changers
again adding to the narrative
and so um
i'm calmer now my daughter
it's funny when i finished this morning
my daughter was sitting outside she was
sitting in the back and she said mom i
think you had a little bit too much
coffee when you were talking about that
yes in the center
from charlottesville virginia
um and uh thank you for today and i've
been hearing the word reconciliation
come up in a number of different ways um
and my question is about the growing
movement for truth-telling and
reconciliation process in the united
states to grapple with the legacies of
racial harm um like in south africa or
and as we hear more and more calls for
reconciliation we're going to have to
grapple more with what that means
um and i've been hearing from several of
you
the term reconciliation be used more
in the context of civil war memorials
almost as reconciliation between
northern and southern whites
over the bodies of african americans um
in the nader period so my question is um
as the u.s kind of tries to figure out
what what reconciliation might mean in
this present day what role do you think
that
the interpretation or reinterpretation
of civil war sites and memorials might
play in that and especially in sort of
informing the conversation about how
white supremacy has
impeded reconciliation
between between the races and sort of to
to repair racial harm
okay um
can i jump in wait okay so
um first of all one of the things that
that's always been a little annoying to
me is that we tend to tend to
place racism and white supremacy as a
solely southern phenomenon
and quite frankly it's part of the
reason why the white north and the white
south are able to reconcile and are able
to frame this narrative of brother
against brother
right
um
so the idea of reconciliation the
question that you're asking about how
can communities reconcile
one for one thing you're assuming there
is conciliation to begin with
right
so i think part of
at least my hope why i get up and go to
work every day
is that it is my hope
that instead what we're talking about is
how do we make our communities
recognize that our history isn't just
spherical i've said this before it isn't
just a circle that we're looking at and
we're trying to get all sides of the
circle
the reality is it's a sphere
it has substance it has weight it has
dimension inside outside all around it
and depending on how you pivot it
you're going to see something remarkably
different the question is do you want to
hold it in your hand
or are you perfectly content to keep
looking at the same side all the time
missing the richness of who we are as
americans in this global environment see
that's the thing to me that's my hope is
that if we keep doing this and if we do
it right then what we're achieving here
is helping people each moment each
little piece
get it
begin to see that the fiber is far more
complex and and and quite frankly
pulling the thread isn't necessarily
taking something away it may reveal
something more powerful
so that's why i have you know through
this whole debate and i have been
questioned many times
you know my mere gender my mere uh
racial or ethnic identity
ethnic identity um
this has been questioned at different
points in time because i'm one of those
people say you know
it's not the statue that worries me
i would i am the person that says let's
expand it let's expand out let's talk
about who we were at these moments in
time
because that's what the generations are
asking us
that's what i see every day in my work
and so um
you know and it's very easy to wet
ourselves to one idea and not want to
change anything because it's worked for
us
it is the things that have reinforced us
clean question down here okay
at holster from richmond
i'm i'm wondering when we're going to
expand this discussion and professor
jordan you touched it briefly when are
we going to expand this discussion to
talk about
the founding fathers and the challenges
with liberty and slavery um it seems to
me that we've we've covered a lot of
ground today and certainly you've
provided
great food for thought
helped me get my head around this a
little more but why
was there only one reference to
to washington as being a slave owner
and what do you feel
needs to be done with regard to our
founding fathers and their statues
speak to that um
the point is not so much that
individuals had um
like washington was a slaveholder
jefferson slave hunter the reason the
confederacy is a separate topic is the
confederacy was a project designed
specifically and exclusively to
perpetuate slavery
that's a different topic that's that is
not why jefferson
was a revolutionary in 1776
although his his racial background
is you know slave following background
is not irrelevant
but the confederacy is a distinct topic
jim just a quick comment uh i think we
need
before we remove washington's name from
every grade school in america
that has it i think we need to ask the
question did we name it washington grade
school because he owned slaves
is that why he's famous did we name it
that because we value his owning slaves
i think to ask that question is to
answer it no we named it that
at our best despite his owning slaves um
being more honest we named it that
because it wasn't even relevant to us
whether he owned slaves but still we
didn't do it because he owned slaves and
for that matter washington actually did
kind of free his slaves we all know why
some of you know why i say kind of he
freed them at his
wife's death for various reasons she
freed them it turns out before she died
because it gradually dawned on her
on the entire plantation everybody
wanted her dead except her
down here hi my name is jim altiri i
live in richmond and it's been a really
great day thank you all it's been a it's
been a great discussion and i think one
of the high points of the discussion is
that it's been pretty balanced all along
so
um
it started me thinking though that that
in in
the national state of affairs currently
it doesn't seem to be a very good
balance and i'm thinking about the
national political situation now the
move toward populism and what's going on
in washington how how does this
discussion fit in that context
i'd like to answer that
please
i'm not normally given to be an alarmist
but that election happened three months
ago and look at where we are now
as a civil war historian someone who
looks at the past to try to get an idea
of how to deal with the president and
the future frankly i'm alarmed i'm alone
by the
by the vehemence
the uh
the the the hatred the angry rhetoric
and i can assure you there are parallels
between the rhetoric of 2016 and the
rhetoric of 1860 at least according to
my own research so i'm terribly
concerned
at this point we have individuals going
around saying hell trump hail trump hell
our people hail our victory which only
serves to remind me that american
democracy regardless of what you might
think ladies and gentlemen american
democracy is extremely
fragile
it's extremely fragile
and i do not like lincoln i do not
believe the house will fall i do not
believe the republic will fall but i am
terribly concerned about how we
americans are dealing with each other in
such a short time span since our last
presidential election it's almost
unparalleled since since lincoln's
election
so i'm very concerned about that i don't
want to sound like an alarmist but
that's how i feel
if i could comment on that i appreciate
your comments about this discussion and
i appreciate irvin's comments about the
state of our country perhaps if
we all left
and told our friends that you can have a
civil discourse
over
a subject of controversy over which
honest right-meaning people can disagree
perhaps is a lesson to be learned from
this session today because i think we
have had a
civil discourse about a
hot topic
john koski now before you ask your
question john
everybody in the audience let's give
john koski a round
he he thought this topic up
he developed it in his mind
he was the one who invited the
participants and as
dr jordan said he was the one who
strong-armed some of the participants
who said no and john would not let them
say no so
john
who would you like to ask what of now so
much for an anonymous question huh
well having insisted on civility and
constructive uh discussion i'm going to
ask a question calculated to get them
throwing their chairs at each other
we had wonderful presentations this
morning about the soldier monuments that
after all represent by far the majority
of monuments north and south and
the the context for their building
obviously as we heard was uh their
erection was about mourning the dead and
the sacrifices of the men and it's not
just a southern phenomenon it's a
national phenomenon more not monuments
in the north uh
and we heard really the background of
them and then uh dr lohan referred to
that the fact that most of them were
built or erected during the nader period
1890 1940
which suggests
that you know they're not as maybe as
innocent uh as as represented by their
inscriptions or by their their poses and
artistic qualities and and and
all the fights that we're seeing today
all the debates are not just about lee
and jackson and and davis in particular
and those are not the only statues that
are under discussion under debate so i
want to ask all of you
given what we heard the collective of
what we heard today
what becomes of the common soldier
monument uh those built to
to to memorialize the dead and the men
who who served uh some of them have have
been
have either been removed or their plans
to remove them what should be done with
those
who i would say first of all
many of them and most of the ones that
went up at first
are at cemeteries
and i don't hear
i'm trying to think i don't think i've
heard of any requests
from
shall we say the black community or from
white
i don't hear any requests to move them
or to take them down
i don't see anything
wrong with them exactly i have a
particular problem maybe with the one at
arlington um
because that's a product of the nader
and it's kind of a federal government
involvement there and many people
completely misconstrue it on purpose i
think to to assert that there were huge
numbers of african americans who were
in the troops and stuff uh which is not
not the case so maybe that one at the
very least needs a bunch of
contextualization around it uh but what
i hear people arguing forth that they're
okay with if if we take for instance
this one from montgomery county from the
courthouse from the position of power
from the place that it got put during
the nader and if we put it at a
confederate cemetery or even
any other cemetery
they're okay with that
i i don't think you really have had a
very much debate about common soldier
monuments really there's this rockville
one the one in louisville um
is part of a a pattern that is um as we
said these you know these are community
decisions and different communities are
different kinds and one kind of
community is colleges
and uh the one in louisville is
basically on a university of louisville
campus
and that's also of course even more true
of silence sam in north carolina and and
so those um ones i think i would
describe more as college cases than
common soldier cases most of the
controversy has been about jefferson
davis who's gone from texas and um it
has expanded to the high command to
people like lee and other generals and
force but so far i have not really heard
a lot of
controversy over common soldier
monuments and i'd be surprised really to
hear it
i think there's
something about the common soldier
that's really quite
affecting i was shocked i was shocked
james garfield was
so bit he was a soldier during the war
and he just lost any faith in the
meaning of what they were fighting for
because he saw so much death and i
quoted him earlier
and
i think the common soldier
monument
is
necessary
to say that what
you know as that's a striking statement
because it's both both signs
but
it's necessary to to remember that they
what they did and what they took
responsibility for
and
oxford charlottesville there's so many
where the hospitals were where the
colleges were where they could find
places for the wounded that's where the
those monuments are but
i i think they're saying some something
about how
the the citizen is taking a role in the
destiny of he of their
country and that has real import for
better or worse but that that's what
their claim is and it is meaningful and
it is that's what they're saying it's
hallowed ground it's important the
ground is important where the dead are
is important
so
i would add that no decent person would
want to desecrate anyone's grave i
certainly wouldn't want to desecrate the
grave of anyone even the worst slave
owner holder in history i would not
desecrate the grave a few years ago
during highway construction the grave of
a confederate soldier was found and it
was decided to have a ceremony for him
here in richmond uh for the
funeral serving and everything and the
whites were concerned about what the
black community's reaction was going to
be today and
the spokesman for the black community
made a very profound statement he said
god will judge we have no objections
and he can't hurt us now
and that's pretty much been my attitude
especially for the common soldier
louis martin from charlottesville uh
hello again miss simon
professor irvin a professor irvin uh
made the uh the comment about uh paul
goodloe mcintyre and that's really the
only reason that those two statues are
in charlottesville because
charlottesville otherwise would have
been able to afford something like that
and that relates to to my comment and
that is um my grandparents and great
aunts and great uncles and their friends
would have been
around lee park at the time that that
statue was dedicated and
so what i've been hearing since 2015 is
that these statues were put up with a
racist and white supremacist animus
but at the same time
when i was a student at the university
of virginia i had a number of friends
that were from uh new england some were
from boston when i was in the army i was
with people who were men who were from
boston
and um
their grandparents and great aunts and
great uncles i believe felt the same way
about that statue of robert gould shaw
and the 54th massachusetts as my
grandparents and great aunts and great
uncles and their friends felt about the
robert e lee and stonewall jackson
statues and so i'd like to hear you
comment on that um as to uh you know
why there would be a difference um from
people in the south and people in the
north because my experience in life has
been that we're all pretty much the same
and then the other issue and this is uh
to miss coleman
i heard you speak about both adding to
the narrative and then um changing the
narrative and uh i think that everybody
agrees that we should add to the
narrative but when you talk about
changing the narrative that starts to
sound a little overwhelming to me
changing the narrative implies that the
questions that are being asked change
and because the questions that new
generations ask are often different
the narrative also changes it's not that
you're changing or trying to become a
willian
it is that in fact generations ask a
different question generations of women
are now asking the question and have
been asking the question what role did
we play we certainly didn't just sit
around making socks what else did we do
and because they are asking different
questions and because the scholarship is
there the documents are there that once
we dig in with those new questions we
find new information the narrative
changes
it is added to
it isn't just the narrative that women
are doing this thing or that thing do
you understand what i'm saying
that is what i mean by changing the
narrative
expanding the narrative means as we know
those things we make space for even more
questions to be asked
and when there are more questions that
are getting answered
our narrative continues to expand it is
never a zero-sum game
and that's what worries me the earlier
question about our political positions
and where we are it is always presented
as if it is a zero-sum game that somehow
if i open this up if i make somebody
else's voice a part of what has always
been there an american experience that i
have to give up something it is that
equality means oppression and equality
has never meant oppression
so
in this discussion
about how shall we remember
that is if you hear nothing else from me
that is what i hope that you will take
away from the experience today
and what we've been so desperately
trying to do in our institution and in
museums like ours around the country
jim would you like to i've got to um we
we just cannot make
the united states and the confederate
states morally equivalent we cannot do
that it's bad history i already said to
you flatly
meaning all of you that the united
states did not go to war to end slavery
that's true
but pretty soon it did go to war to end
slavery i mean it continued in the war
to end slavery now
during that time
all kinds of folks in the united states
army and for that matter at home too
because they wrote home to their to
their loved ones and their families and
their girlfriends and so on um became
less racist towards african-americans
there's maybe two reasons for that one
is
the
idea of cognitive dissonance and some of
you maybe know what that means and some
of you don't but basically it means if
you do stuff for example in this case if
you do stuff against slavery it's really
hard to say slavery is right and the
reason it's right is because those black
folks are inferior and they need to be
told what to do
because in that case what you're doing
makes no sense and people do not like to
say to themselves what i'm doing makes
no sense so they're going to change
their attitudes to say you know yeah
and of course there was opposition in
the united states army and across the
north to the emancipation proclamation
when it first came out but by 1864 it
was pretty much in favor of it and we
see that for instance in maryland uh
maryland you know it's one of the few
places in the history of the world ever
to vote out slavery uh which they did in
a separate referendum on that part of
their constitution in i believe late
1864
and
when the civilian population got done
voting
slavery had narrowly passed
retaining it had passed but they hadn't
counted the absentee ballots the
absentee ballots of course were
overwhelmingly from
people involved in the war and they were
nine to one for freedom and that shows
both cognitive dissonance and it also
shows that people had come into contact
with african americans fighting next to
them or telling them the best way to get
to uh
jackson and then which road to take to
get to vicksburg and doing you know they
just came into contact with them in ways
they had never done before so the united
states gradually became less racist
which led to the 14th and 15th
amendments and the good things passed
during reconstruction
and meanwhile some confederates did too
mahon and longstreet and
not just a few names but but others
having spent four years on behalf of
white supremacy found it very difficult
indeed impossible to argue for black
equality in 1866 and 1867 and so on and
so they the confederate officers in
particular formed the core of the ku
klux klan so we just cannot say well
they both fought well we could say that
much but and they both felt from fought
for morally equivalent causes we can't
say that part
yes ma'am in the middle uh my name is
evie terrano i'm a professor at history
at randolph-macon college up in ashland
thank you so very much for all your
perspectives but
the confederate commemorate landscape
was largely dormant until the racist
violence of 2015 activated oppositional
perspectives and particularly of course
energize the black lives matter movement
to create new discourses around these
monuments are you concerned that the
potential removal of this confederate
landscape might not
[Music]
necessitate not only acquiescing the
history but also as we move forth
eradicating a platform for oppositional
voices
we'd like to handle that
um well i think you're um i
agree entirely with your premise and i
think uh as as you well know um
that's something that we should bear in
mind is most monuments peak on
dedication day right the thousands of
civil war monuments in the united states
most of them the peak of their public
influence was the day they were
dedicated in many cases the monument was
put up so they could have the dedication
ceremony that's what people wanted was
the dedication ceremony even more than
this thing would be there forever and
they have been in long decline ever
since and are you know in in some form
of senescence
um so we have this um this kind of
zombie phenomenon in some ways that is
it is an interesting kind of cultural
problem
and i guess i would i would just offer
um as someone who lives in the core of
the confederacy um and enjoys visiting
uh this um
post-sumpter latecomer up here
um
the experience of south carolina
that
um
although there's a lot to be said for
expanding the narrative and adding that
well chosen repudiation
um is uh an important part of the
toolkit
south carolina
removed the confederate flag from the
state house grounds after the murders of
2015.
and it certainly didn't make everything
better in south carolina i'm not
claiming that but it did make things
better than they were before
and it did
to some extent
disarm
confederate legacy at large
um because it's its most powerful
symbol had been repudiated
so i i do think that um
a well-chosen repudiation can be an
important part of the toolkit
it's interesting
because while all of that was happening
there was something else going on while
they were coming down
groups like the virginia flagger started
going private property owners and
putting up 40 and 50 foot tall
battle flags
while that was going on even in our own
gift shops we were getting phone calls
in our gift shop asking us if we sold
battle flags
confederate flags they wanted
now for us it turned into an educational
opportunity well which one
because that's what we do
um but there was a spike a significant
spike in our sales and we had to have an
internal conversation
about that
um so yeah it may have come down in
public space
but for some it made them even more
ardent
in their desire to deal with and to
protect or to reinforce or to reassert
the meaning of those things for them
does that make sense
and so i think that um
what ends up happening is this this
remarkable push and pull and
you know i i think um
you know
certainly the the charleston murders
were lightning rod in and of themselves
for these questions because of what that
young man
what the murderer had in his hands
what is compelling to me is why is that
the first time
that that becomes the thing
they said anything about you know
tim mcveigh or the guys even this week
the four people that were arrested this
week in their rhetoric
and their plots of terrorism
fortunately several of them were were
foiled but it doesn't get the same
attention it doesn't seem to
we don't
we turn a blind's eye to some of this
sometimes and we just have to you know
we have to be careful and is that fair i
mean is that fair to put all of that
weight
on either a symbol or a statue or a
movement
like black lives matter or any is it
fair to put all of that weight on them
when there is um
it isn't just the moment
it is all of the things leading to the
moment
okay let's make one last uh short
question if we could
is it four o'clock
really hello uh so
uh i'm from the north first of all uh
and
i just recently moved to richmond from
louisiana actually so i kind of went
from new hampshire
welcome to the south y'all
thank you
um
and so my exposure to a lot of this is
somewhat new um
you know if if anything if we heard
about it uh which we mostly didn't uh
growing up um
it was very localized or something where
uh
it wasn't a hot button discussion topic
where i was
but
i do want to kind of ask where you folks
think
the direction of this discussion goes
especially with
my generation
going forward with
the millennials that are you know coming
through um
what do you think
becomes part of that
discussion and
do you think it will be about
uh the meeting or will be maybe more
about financials instead uh
talking about
where does this go from here you know 20
30 years from now your your generation
will tell the 21st century mine won't
but yours will
and so you're going to pass on what
where it's there's that generational
shifting and it is the fact that they
still the shiloh monument went up in
2015
a mississippi courthouse confederate
monument
went up in 2016 i mean just months ago
so that movement as it certainly peaked
2011 2000 i'm sorry 1911 1950 peak then
but there's there's still
energy that is still ongoing and this
lightning rolling of the boy with a gun
and a flag i mean just shows that you
know how that
it can still elicit these powerful
emotions in both ways and so it's not
it's not that it's not the generation
behind us it's not the wartime
generation it's not the generation it
came in it's it's this general and then
you all
so to speak and then and then the
generation
that the 21st century was going to
inherit what we're talking about today
and they will have to reconcile to use
your
word
still
okay
ladies and gentlemen i'm afraid we are
out of time
i want to thank and ask you to well
join me in thanking this excellent panel
of speakers
[Applause]
now i'd like to get the speakers to join
me in thanking this wonderfully civil
audience on this topic
[Applause]
finally i'd like to thank the library of
virginia for co-hosting with us and the
now center at the university of virginia
i hope everybody has enjoyed it and
i'm sorry no closing remarks uh thanks
very much for coming
and it will be on c-span starting
saturday night the 25th
all day we've been live from richmond
virginia with the symposium on civil war
monuments and memorials you can watch
all of today's symposium on our website
at cspan.org history
and you can watch all of the programs we
feature on american history tv and find
our tv schedule
and to connect with us follow us on
twitter and facebook